le raid est lancé
la caméra rives ça prend un peu de temps
de tout de tout les laudes et
donc ça c'est la partie d'alireza contre
sa chique et riant et nous on va aller
bordeaux 2 on va attendre que la caméra
voilà s'ouvre et on a maxime donc à la
caméra en pleine réflexion donc ça
renforce que j'étais en train de dire un
là c'est pas du bluff maxime ne se
rappelle plus il réfléchit
et ça y est on le voit il vient de jouer
tour donc c'était le coup
le coup donné
on va voir shirov revenir à la table
peut-être
vous allez voir il est vraiment grand
shirov
regardez regardez la taille du bonhomme
c'est un géant shirov c'est vraiment un
géant
il est il est vraiment il fait s'il fait
3 maxime en fait
ouais c'est un titan
quittant scheer au val
bas il est vraiment très très grand et
très imposant a et coupe mulet bien sûr
ah bah oui coupe mulet un sa part 1
1 saint jehan suis pas ci fais pas de m
il est il est vraiment immense
petit ennui talhouët c'est le titan lui
d'étals je pense
mais la coupe la coupe mulet qui caries
non cotées côté shirov
ça déconcentre quand même
de mettre deux mulets ouais
non il a certes physiquement il est il
ay ay
il polio pose les bases quoi
ah non ils posent clairement il faut
mieux que ça reste une partie d'échecs
pour maxime aujourd'hui
à lens bien là en chasse boxing à mon
avis contre shirov t'es pas bien
non non non et tu étais pas bien du tout
d'ailleurs maxime l'aï respecté
rencontre sachy quirion ça marchait on
l'a contre shirov ça respecte ça revient
s'asseoir
ça va pas faire les allers-retours à
pied aujourd'hui côté côté ministériel
oui là
là tu te rappelles tu rappelles les
baskets shirov
anders et shirov qui va se lever à mon
avis
ou pas ça peut repartir à tout moment
magnifique
donc ces actions la position qu'on avait
vu à l'instant des cinq qui avait eu
cette
inde et 5 avec le fou prend 1,3 et
cavaliers aux 7
avec son mulet shirov rendre encore un
peu plus dans la légende un magnifique
harry gare et joue à domicile alors
après il est parti vivre en espagne il
joue pour l'espagne où il a joué pour
l'espagne en tout cas mais il est lé ton
on sait de quel acier
il est fait de quel métal plutôt
il se chauffe
c'est qu'il a une chaise qui pourrait
exploser un shirov
donc
prendre trois ça va jouer là ça va jouer
exactement la préparons la prépa
bitstream 1 3 c'est terrible c'est
exactement la position que j'avais
montré il ya trois mois
lorsque j'avais commenté la partie
farruggia carlson ferroudja c'est pas
possible
trois mois plus tard la position arrive
sur l'échiquier
du coup il a pris de la dame
et il se lève donc là ces cavaliers
sinko
car il est prend 1,5 puis on prend 1,5
dames 35 dont qui légalise le matériel
l'acsl à la pause
mais
ouais
ça ça me paraissait moins dangereux
personnellement
c'est moins dangereux
mais à des idées 1
mais ça me paraît pas
écrasant mais ya peut-être des dames qui
viennent en a sept qui sont chiantes
peut être chiante la dame là bas
c'est peut-être ça l'idée façon y ait
une idée hein c'est sûr
et c'est sûr que si maxime est parti là
dedans c'est qu'ils ont trouvé des
choses avec baky un
an de façon cavalière 5 c'est plus ou
moins forcé car il est des huit c'est
sean ces dames cette cavale et db4 ces
dames des quatre donc à rio 5 force et
cavaliers prends tu vas quand même faire
puis on prend
le pion tu vas le beauf et
peut-être dame c3 aussi mais bon en gros
c'est quand même mais
bon elle a du coup on part du principe
que les blancs ont ce truc chiant
peut-être qu'il faut justement pas faire
tout réduite les tours des huit pour
essayer de taper l'a
fait gagner un temps quoi
ok ça ça va être dangereux pour les
noirs très clairement
ok qui a rallié aux cinq jouer
on va voir la question qu'on me pose
c'est jusqu'à quel point shirov est prêt
maxime st cyr il a poussé le vieux
jusqu'au bout attendre la faute ah ouais
euh
je dois te dire
que
untel comme shirov à mon avis tient
mieux qu'un tel comme naguère c'est pas
tout à fait la même classe
je suis assez content l'ouverture 1 pour
maxime j'ai l'impression qu'il a une
idée quelque part et que ça peut
représenter danger
donc je suis assez assez optimiste et
surtout il ya aucun danger aucun risque
de défaite pour lui donc c'est cool
j refaire un joueur à l'ancienne il
reste beaucoup à 6 il reste tout le
temps concentré à l'ancienne par contre
je suis inquiet pour sa chique et riant
ce cas position et rico nuss mais déjà
plombé
et la jouer rouages suite ok on va
rester sur maxime parce que la partie
s'anime un petit peu donc a valu aux
cinq épreuves 5 comprend 1,5 dame prend
1,5
maxime quand même qui reprend son temps
on sait jamais qui est du dam c3
il allait prendre en la vue
on a vu allez prendre maxime il avait le
droit au dessus du pion et puis là une
petite hésitation il a dû voir le dame
c3 aussi possible voire même un tour
assez 1 mais voilà il prend le pion il a
juste voulu vérifier qu'ils ratent pas
vraiment quelque chose mesdames
champions
et ça repart
et là c'est peut-être pas si simple si
vous avez vu la partie de carlson compte
chiroux déjà vous devez savoir qu'il ya
un problème avec les pions a6b
saint-cloud bessette ça peut on peut
être un peu fixé sur blanc ça peut être
un problème dans très longtemps avec les
fous de même couleur et il doit y avoir
un peu d'activité avec da macadam des
quatre dames à 7 qui est pénible
et le pion c'est qu'ils évitent sous
pression
là encore avec un jeu parfait les noirs
doit pouvoir tenir n'y a pas deux
doit pas y avoir avoir une voix il ne
doit pas y avoir de soucis insurmontable
pour les noirs mais il faut réaliser le
coup parfait et ça c'est toujours le
même problème aux et chacun
3 sur lequel vous dis tourbe et 8,7
l'ordi d'amd 4
et damas est
et genre là même si on échange comme ça
on va être mal avec les normes rail à
tour à 8
malheureusement
en fait joué juste dire que savait pas
d'enfermement de bam l'option a été
vraiment proche de dames et que cela
pouvait représenter un énorme danger
c'est déjà une première idée dangereuse
c'est peut-être pas la salle en
d'ailleurs mais ça c'est tu passes tu
tapissier ici ça peut être pénible
david howell qui fait une grotte contre
issy piankov bon ça m'étonnerait mais on
va aller voir
non pas du tout alors ça ça va être
banal instantanément
à un ban
de dix minutes
histoire de et puis après on passera sur
du panerai fin
et après on passera sur du band f
là c'est important pour achir of
là c'est quoi important
après ce que je comprends il ya un kif
pour mettre la tourbe et en a huit
dames des cats et met la d'amendés 6
pour couvrir à 6 pour sur damas est
avoir foi en 8es à voir aussi les idées
avec tours à huit qui enferme la dame
dame décide ça a l'air d'être un coup
fort parce que ça donne aussi du dame b
4 dans certains hedge qui tape ici et
apithy et apithy
d'indécis sans vraiment être un coup clé
possibles
investisseurs lit pas fan du tout réussi
mais moi j'aime bien
ton que huit d'amd si j'aime bien pour
les noirs
on se rappelle pas plus loin je pense
qu'il connaissait jusque là
et là il commence à jouer par lui-même
les tours f18 dam des cas d'amd système
des cartes d'amd si
le truc futur
27.8 ok la diff
c'est qu'en fait cette tour gentil fait
tour 3
c'est pour illustrer
à pato reprend 1,3 parce qu'il ya dame
prend des huit ce que tu aurais eu en
ayant les tours comme ça
j'aurais peut-être partie surtout bd
huit
as et un
bref huit étapes adam france et 7 passes
qui a tout reprend un délit et dame
reprend ses sept
du ku'damm cas tout re en prison et
d'amendés 6 maintenant
damas 7 x 8
c'est un [ __ ] ça peut être long ça
peut être vraiment relou pour les noirs
abstiens l'art de rien c'est hyper
chiant
et la tête déjà un peu bloquée
tu tapes ici tu tapes ici
je tape un peu ici il va devoir faire
tour c8
et là ça se sent que t'es pas au mieux
mais clairement la dame elle se dirige
vers cette case ouvert cette case
like this way
la percée réchauffement ouais c'est
chiant à vrai dire
à mars
les positions avec les noirs tu es
toujours un peu sous pression que tu
fous une âge d'or que tu une espagnole
que tu quoi que ce soit tu as toujours
être sous pression même si leurs 10 mai
00 c'est chiant
les cales et chiante à jouer ça là pour
pour alexeï
c'est encore le nombre de spas et le
kilométrage élevé elle pour le concours
de marche il faudrait 1
clairement shirov là il est en pleine
réflexion il est plus du tout dans
l'après paris les îles et dans le calcul
positions de travail position de calcul
d'à côté
côté espagnol
ces cinq est envisageable c'est bizarre
comme coup mais ouais
après faut voir aussi ce qui se passe
sur des 6 1
parce que ce pion il est fort calme
ce pion il est fort
ni encore et encore beaucoup de coups
pour
pour les blancs
m
pour bénédicte sans cammas c'est logique
mais la vendre qu'on a vu c'est un peu
pénible il faut trouver comment
ont pêché en fait il faut réussir à
minimiser la gêne ans de la dame en a 7
semble être la ligne de l'ordi
l'idée c'est que t'as pas le problème de
la tourbe et 8 qui gênait est allé dame
b 4 dans le règne qui j'aime les blancs
donc tourbe et 8 semble intéressant
ouais
c'est vrai tour est fluide dam des
quatre
dames décide damas est ce assez chiant
ou à 8 tours 3
ouais ça c'est chiant parce que la tour
en b vital est mal placé mais c'est
hyper dur à comprendre
comprendre il ya peut-être d'autres
finesse qu'on n'a pas encore compris
hein
je peux pas manger le pionner parce que
tout à l'heure si manger le pion des tu
perds le pion à est super le pion à le
pian il est trop fort
peut-être tu perdais le pion ces
messages et ça dépend de la position
dans laquelle tu parles
madame assad suite dame
5g pas c'est un peu con laisser le pion
en vie quand même
ça avec le pion aux cinq ans vie pour
les noirs ça devait complètement aller
n'a pas du tout les problèmes d'entrée
même sur récupère un pion ben y aura
égalité matérielle
voilà la question évolué pour les noirs
la question est venue parce que c'est
qu'elle tout remettre sur quelles cases
et a beaucoup de choix et c'est dur de
comprendre
je partir pour tourbe et des huit quand
même
torah c'est un tour f18
dam des quatre ris prise
d'anne decis damas est
ça par exemple la turbine est quant à
elle arrivée là elle adore les blancs
konami nommé système est bien à
d'amendés 6 en fait
j'adore être bloc le pion elle protège
là elle va entrer là j'adore la lavande
et 6 tu as peut-être du fou ces huit
fugate part dans leur haine jeu
visuellement elle est bien placé
sa tenue suffire à maxime tu pense et je
sais pas dur à dire
j'ai deux coups sont jouables
très très très très complexe extrêmement
complexe la position
caruana grande et lui serait bien que
fabiano gagne pas
il a pas l'air d'être dans une position
pour gagner pour le moment
ça va jouer un
ici pierre kol
ses adversaires peuvent être dangereux
car tim est finie man marrant nimani
fait son tournoi
c'est pas un mauvais premier appariement
compliqué complexe
ex complexe
sur une charge voit on va aller jeter un
oeil c'est bizarre là
la réflexion de sa chique et riant
voilà oui
ça a l'air déjà dur pour sa chique et
riant le péno comme on l'appelle dans le
jargon
ça peut
perdre ça peut ça peut perdre ça paraît
difficile ce qu'on fait ça tape ici ça
tape ici ça tape ici il a déjà dépensé
40 minutes et la position semble durer
ali reza il semble plus ou moins
connaître ça sent très mauvais pour sa
chique et riant
s'ils gagnent aujourd'hui alireza il se
retrouve à quoi il a reste six points et
demi
ouais alireza s'ils gagnent aujourd'hui
c'est bon
il lui manquerait pas deux nuls peuvent
passer trois nuls le qualifie sur après
l'annoncé sur
tellement dommage qu'il n'ait pas battu
à shirov d'ailleurs il y aurait battu
shirov il aurait eu le même appariement
et là il gagne il était déjà à 7 quoi
c'était il était déjà khalifa avec un
demi point sur trois peut-être
hiruta il est vraiment belle et un demi
point de plus que maxime et ils ont
exactement le même des partages donc ça
veut dire que si maxime gagne
aujourd'hui et qui fait trois nuls ça
devrait pouvoir passer ses réserves
peut-être même deux nuls passe pour lui
donc alireza molla il est là il a
quasiment une balle de qualif
en 2009 les deux joueurs à 8
ouais mais avait plus de joueurs en 2010
aff allemand il faut regarder les
situations d tournoi
sa tennis fera jamais les mecs vont
faire line ils ont plus de 20 à 4 et
demi bref ils vont faire revenir vite
fait un
ça va faire du ce me aline à mon avis
ça va temporiser
ça fait fouleront depuis un moment quand
même bon on verra avec bondé partagent
cet ennemi ça peut passer huit c'est sûr
que ça passe
après là où je suis d'accord c'est que
s'il ya mvl firoud déjà cet ennemi il
peut y en avoir un des deux qui passe
pas c'est assez vrai
truc c'est qu'il y en a qui font en
ligne avec les plans mais ils font tous
les serrures avec les noirs donc au
final ça donne des drones partout
et les niveaux de jeu sont
treize équivalent dans ce tournoi il
manque beaucoup de joueurs du top
mondial
c'est quand même beaucoup de plo versus
plots quoi de partout les plots ont du
mal à se battre à voir la partie de
navarra hier
fab il m'a envoyé le nom fanion voyez le
diagramme hier sur messenger avant qu'on
fasse la vidéo il me dit comment tour
est joué on veut juste trouver le gamin
tempo sans réfléchir quoi
j'avais pas vu la partie est un appareil
laplaud ted tard il a fait le plot aussi
donc il ya aussi le problème des plots
quoi ils ont du mal à terminer les
parties
navarra et arrive avec des positions qui
étaient vraiment très simple à gagner
enfin très simple très simple à gagner
pour des joueurs du top mondial pour
être précis mais des joueurs à 27,56
rate jamais mais le truc c'est qu'il
rate y aura des trucs pas comme
d'ailleurs hier
nager hier parce qu'il a raté en
attendant la finale c'est incroyable
il rate beaucoup quand même en partant
là et ce qu'ils vont vraiment réussir à
mettre des punto c'est pas si sûr
chirac perd cette position je refais 5
se bat ça fait plaisir ça ex now
après il peut y avoir le risque des
parties truquées aussi mais bon j'y
crois pas trop
ouais ce qui peut faire peur par contre
là où je suis d'accord
c'est si à des gars comme messi pianca
radulov caruana qui réussissent à monter
eux vont faire re ligne et peuvent se
faire contrer par les plots quoi et là
ça peut être dangereux en fait c'est un
peu le scénario dangereux puisque j'ai
pas je vois pas des partis vite yougov
pancrate of par exemple fois qu'ils sont
à quatre et demi jet d'encre attaf il va
arriver à faire la vis à cela la vie
c'est en fait il va jamais envoyé au
lean ils vont faire que des droits
trenet qui gagne après le danger ouais
c'est surtout les quatre et demi il y en
a beaucoup qui gagne ça c'est vrai si
sur les je crois qu'il ya douze parties
à 4 points et demi 6 à six parties
décisives c'est vrai que ça peut être
dangereux
si bienne connaissez si bien que ce
n'est pas une fille membre tu sais mieux
lire le cyrillique que moi frérot
rené une belle position il doit gagner
quatre de chute pour fracas ils veulent
dans marianne c'est terminé
je réfléchis beaucoup c'est pas un coup
facile et honnêtement il ya peut-être
une série de coups difficiles ici mais
s'il sort les bons coups il va faire
drôle
je dois dire que les jours précédents il
a très bien défendu shirov mais il peut
être un petit peu fatigué par ses pairs
partie contre issy pianca est contre
et contre firoud déjà on va espérer que
ça allait usé mentalement et
physiquement et qu'ils fassent de la
gaffe
après clairement c'est une partie
importante aussi pour maxime et là où je
suis aussi d'accord avec les punto jeu
dont on parlait précédemment 56 shirov
fait nul il reste à cinq et demi il ya
d'autres gars qui vont arriver à cinq et
demi qui vont vouloir le taper il est un
peu le caractère pour envoyer un all in
et c'est vrai que l'éliminer aujourd'hui
ce serait bien
si maxime 2 si maxime fait nul
aujourd'hui il sera obligé de faire
de faire au moins deux sur trois sur les
trois dernières ouais
ça c'est clair mais moi je pense cet
ennemi passe mais bon après je peux me
tromper
ce qu'elles valent à doubler les blancs
il peut doubler les blancs
se rassied
shirov réfléchi partie très importante
aujourd'hui
avec le mulet est magnifique
la coupe u les magnifiques côté shirov
ya vingt-huit joueurs un demi point
derrière et joue contre eux mais qu'ils
commencent à remonter non mais ça c'est
sûr mais si on a vraiment beaucoup qui
vont monter
ce qu'on attend qu'ils réfléchissent à
fait une demi-heure dans quasiment
fait 25 entre 25 et 30 minutes de
réflexion sur ce coup mais c'est le
premier coup de la partie en réalité
pour un shirov
c'est le plus beau muller le plus beau
mulet pour shirov
mais rld incoming suis pas sûr
c'est un coup vraiment important
le calcul pour rester trente minutes où
il brille c'est
hallucinant tout ce qu'ils peuvent voir
quand ils réfléchissent aussi longtemps
après on peut se mélanger perdre en
lucidité
j'ai 5 vous dit
ouais mais c'est un peu le seul coup tu
as envie de jouer les questions de le
voir c'est fait lecavalier a attaqué tu
fais qu'aller au g5 1 ce cavalier 6
et s'adonnent déjà gagnant pour les
blancs à vrai dire après qu'il rallie au
g5 je regarde la turbine est parce que
je veux pas passer des heures sur la
position mais ça donne déjà plus un 60
mais en plus la rente est logique ce qui
a eu le g5 dames 8 pour éviter cavalier
e 6
et d4
ya la dame à venir en b3 et ça ça sent
ça sent le punto pour pour ali reza
après les réserves avoir besoin de 3
nuls et va sûrement les faire donc c'est
vrai que ça aussi par rapport à la
gestion de tournoi alireza ça va être un
joueur difficile à jouer mais celui
qu'il joue à la dernière avec les blancs
ce que là ils devraient redoubler les
noirs mais celui qui va le jouer sylla
cet ennemi est qu'il ya un autre joueur
à cet ennemi contre lui ça pourra pas
être maxime mais il pourrait avoir une
nulle assuré contre firoud zhao noir
donc c'est un peu si tu as un mec qui
joue blanc blanc noir en fait il peut
mettre deux points et la droit avec les
north à la dernière facile contre firoud
c'est vrai que faut faire gaffe à ça
pour maxime si un autre joueur qui monte
à cet ennemi qui affirme à cet ennemi
est qu'ils jouent ensemble ils feront
tous les 2 8 points c'est sur
mais bon faudrait qu'il ya un gars qui
réussissent à faire de maintenant dans
les gars qui sont à quatre et demi qui
phase 3 sur 3 et ça j'y crois pas en
fait je pense pas que sur cette
multitude de joueurs il y en un qui
réussissent à faire trois sur trois mais
je peux me tromper
après si ça arrive clairement c'est
drogba la dernière contre firoud et
il faut faire un 8 points ce que firent
où il fera drouot sylla cet ennemi fera
droit avec les blancs à la dernière ça
c'est sûr à 100% parce que vu ces sondés
partagent sa le qualifie
dans toute cette multitude de joueurs
faut qu'il y en ait un ouais si on a un
qui fait 3 sur 3
la rouennaise pour le faire non je pense
que s'il ya quelqu'un qui fait 3 sur 3
c'est un plot en contre
mais je vois pas qui
l'auront pas l'air de très bien jouer je
chine que je garde
ça peut être doux bas ça peut être les
six pieds n'co ça peut être macho blue
ça peut être sévillan bizarrement
un truc c'est que t'as d'état d'état
davis comme
ça des serrures comme millions
guillemets s'appuyant guy peut faire nul
aujourd'hui ouais
tu peux avoir du plomb versus plots
versus plots versus flots et que ça
irait
le plus probable c'est un gars à 7
contre fillon à cet ennemi la dernière
d'où le fait que cet ennemi peut ne pas
suffire à max ouais mais max il aura un
meilleur des partages tour bd 8 juin
et je pense pas que ce soit un mec qui
réussissent à faire trois sur trois je
pense pas que ce soit un mec dont on
pense qu'il en est capable bizarrement
je pense c'est vraiment un mec qui
qui a la chance
donc là
garder quoi on avait regardé torah c'est
un touret fuite donc l'idée c'est que
les blancs n'ont pas d'âme français 7 à
cause de tout reprend un échec tour pro
1 et dan france s est
donc du coup on avait regardé dam des
quatre tours prend un tour prendre et
d'amd 6 damas est
alors ici à noter que la turbine and
john ashe 6
et sur damas est du coup franc des 5
vous prend dé 5,2 me prendrait cinq
dames 3 6 il ya tours à huit c'est ça
l'idée
du coup la forêt faire dame pensée set
et ça ce serait égal c'est ce genre de
position que shirov cherche à obtenir
après là c'est vraiment un coup de pouce
du destin
se tourner sans aucun top presque serait
dommage que loupé le coche oui après
c'est clair ça je suis aussi d'accord
avec vous que en soit en l'absence de
tous les joueurs de top niveau il ya
déjà un certain côté de réussite entre
guillemets et c'est sûr que maxime bas
il faudra qu'il fasse les points qui
devra faire un
maxime lui qui garde son masque pour
protéger son adversaire du coc vide
effectivement ce qui n'est pas
obligatoire
moi je vous le dis en toute franchise
personnellement je l'aurais pas me mets
à
s'apprécier des choix personnels
enfin j'aurais mis en déplacement entre
les tables ça oui mais mais là la table
je n'aurai pas de perso
en comptant qui n'est pas obligatoire
bien évidemment s'il avait été
obligatoire je leur ai mis ça c'est sûr
ça dérange pas c'est mieux comme ça
ouais non c'est sûr après moi je dis ce
que j'aurais fait personnellement chacun
fait ce qu'il veut mais là pour un
tournoi machin truc de haut niveau
je me serais dit je suis la règle et
puis basta
après tu as peut-être des gens qui
maxime il est peut-être plus confort
avec un aussi
ça a précédé choix très personnel sont
des choix très personnel
fear où il a vraiment l'air très très
bien en plus si c'est le vih ou tempo il
doit connaître affirme déjà ça peut être
pedneault
sirou peut faire peiné aujourd'hui
position a déjà l'air complètement
écrasante pour ali reza qui va peut-être
gagner dans l'ouverture
d'ailleurs m v elle est 100% qualifier
pour le grand prix à saint louis
pierrot le roule dessus quand même
pauvre plein air il est vraiment fort
alireza
disons qu ali reza ce soir si maxime et
shirov font nul il aurait un point
d'avancé sur tout le monde c'est énorme
c'est ce qu'a fait lui restera quoi pour
se qualifier les grands prix fidh
février mars avril
donc
à
bob ho là là
heureusement que jette en l'air mon
téléphone sinon j'y pense pas
là on n'était pas bien les six minutes
de plus par heure qui partait pas
c'était très problématique sauvé par la
pub
bah oui 44 minutes de stream une petite
pub de trois minutes un la petite plus
bas ce qui par
ça fait du bien
ça y est on souffle enfin
on souffle à
souffle
à laon souffler on souffle bien là
j'espère qu'un maximum de gens ont eu la
pub 1
j'espère j'espère
donc maxime et qu'est-ce qui va tenter
pour mettre la pression
cg organique annuelle firoud 3 mondial
faudrait vérifier web façon chiroux déjà
à mon avis vu le garçon ait vu le
tempérament qui l'a qu'ils soient 4e 3e
5e ou deuxième mondial ils sont balech
totalement je sais pas vous mais firoud
jazz se sent le mec
pour qui seule la première place compte
je sais pas comment vous le sentez de
votre côté
mais je sens pas le gars qu'ils en aient
quelque chose à faire dés 4e 3e ou 2e 1
c'est une montagne edwin airways oies
mais il veut démolir carte scène
s'éclaire si on arrive à avoir la foi n
dali furent à la qualif est à la fin de
second suisse imaginait le grand prix
fields à 100% des herbes acquis entre
eux de façon 100 % derrière bas qui quoi
qu'il en soit un hautbois là il faut
quand même être sérieux dans le tchat
le président avant tout un
oui
sans seul sedee a
qualifié ici ou qualifiante ou le frérot
elle est aux abois beaucoup plus
qu'elles veulent sans doute c'est
l'impression que ça donne mais maxime
chansons qu'il a beaucoup bossé aussi
méfie rojas à 100 qui bossent beaucoup
globalement il a tellement progressé
depuis six mois un an là
ce qui est dans l'équipe de fuir ou on
sait qu'ils achètent par enough mais on
n'en sait pas grand chose
ma mère est russe et elle me confirme
que le haut se prononce au nom mais en
fait se prononça son nom à ses 6 pieds
car ça c'est pas ici pied mco
à la peine de sa rente et de s'inventer
des la f1 il trouve que je le sais
pas c'est plus de saillé cipn cas mais
il se trouve que je le sais
on se trouve que son analyse ce prénom
c'est comme ça et j'y peux rien
elle peut se sa maman peut tout à fait
se tromper parce que ça pourrait se
prononcer ici plein cours donc de base
ça devrait se prononcer y est si plein
comme il se trouve qu'avec lui c'est ici
plein car j'y peux rien
que pour ce nom là c'est comme ça mais
après
très possible que sa maman se trompent
pas
sur google traduction tu l'aimés
phonétiquement et je sortais scipione
cas mais c'est sûr que ça y est si plein
cas
m
lorsque maxime à mes tours bene vite
fait les deux coups qui semblait bon
c'était tourbe et des 8es tourbe et 1,8
il a choisi tour bdc le coup j'aurais
pris après analyse avec turbine a été
sans
sait comment le plan des blancs j'ai
déjà montré se soient tapé sur ces 7 ou
décaler la dame vera 7
après il peut y avoir des plans avec
tours troyes tours j'ai trois mais ça
paraît un peu nigel un peu court
surtout que tours troyes il y aurait
tout de suite tour 8 en fait on réussir
est tout de suite à empêcher la tour
l'arrivée de la tour en g3 je sens un
maxime un peu un kit un peu inquiets
mais
ça se voit qu'il n'a pas pris le dessus
je dirais non
s'il ya pas sur l'eau donc ça se pense
comme un à courser au uniquement si un
accent aussi la voyelle placée proche
d'un accent ouais mais il faut que le
haut soit passé avant s'il aurait placé
après l'accent ça va souvent sierra
quand même
ça se voit qu'il est moins serein la
maxime aujourd'hui chira face sorties
l'ouverture qu'il fallait zoko moureaux
serait beau ça
si le groupe
c'est comme france qui se prononce
france reste tout à fait ça
il résonne chez roush magnifique
inchy rave ya une et quand didot
que magnus refuge contre lui trop
faibles
et yann moquera c'est magnifique
bokkie quoi aller
boxer lambeaux crown
java java vous et
au constat n'accostera horus iphone au
cateau mais c'est que les acquis se
change en eau les amis et les rockies
changeant à
léo qui changera mais là ne change pas
en eau
film aux arrêts
merci amorgos pour pour les 5 saab
wesley ça pas mal pas mal wesley ça
ouais
sur scène on s'échange des prix pour qui
une fois ci dans la foulée trouble et
une nulle
il vient d'où le nom des douches pour
nov ouais je sais pas il y avait un
punto et dos santos et il y avait 12 ou
il ya eu 12 bonne touche
je sais pas c'est parti comme ça
langage fort poil de maxime mais pas
excellent l ouverture et papa était une
réussite aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'est sûr qu'il ne se repose pas et
continue de bosser c'est terrible la
mort vous
philippe nauche non non passe à
l'origine
l'origine c'est baky
l'origine c'est pas qui dit j'en vois un
punto
et moi un moment donné après si j'envoie
dos santos on était dans un délire de
stream
brésilien tête une partie contre krikor
et du coup s'est transformé de dos punto
sans douche puntos
est en fait de l'origine c'est baky qui
j'envoie un punto
alors qu'ils voulaient dire personne en
fait mais il aurait dit punto et du coup
quelques stream plus tard c'est parti en
dose puntos et ça c'est transformer
instantanément en douche pour noces et
du coup c'est resté parce que c'était
marrant
dans ce pays sa charge tous jouez en
mode zéro prise de risque qui
recherchent deux variantes à de
résultats
non et enfin ferait beaucoup davantage
de life en fait c'est concret les échecs
au bout d'un moment là tu veux faire tu
veux mettre la pression d'où tu parles
de de résultats frérot
c'est pas c'est pas faim fondamentaux
quand tu te rendes pas sur des lives
quoi tu calcules il cherche à prendre
l'aventage à mettre en danger shirov ne
peut pas être mis en danger mais ce qui
peut vraiment mettre en danger shirov
c'est la question
vous jouez quoi
l'adamant sa-7 pouvait être un problème
les pions a6b 5 peuvent être un problème
dans une finale mais le truc c'est que
c'est pas faisait route déjà en face et
maxime n'est pas magnus et shirov il
défend pas mal dé finale en fait
il faut trouver un truc qui met shirov
en danger et pas tout échanger
rapidement et faire drôle quoi
après nullis y est pas
et pas un si mauvais résultat pour
maxime il reste dans le groupe il a cinq
il aura cinq points sera dans un groupe
avec cinq six joueurs il faudra faire
deux points pour pour se qualifier 1
2 point mi mai
[Musique]
mai
peut être contre des joueurs qui vont
devoir forcer avec les blancs donc il
peut les contrer avec sa nage d'un fait
avec les noirs est allé chercher le
point
du doigt il a cinq et demi avec deux
points sur trois il peut passer deux
points et demi il sera sûr
déjà ça oui bon il ya cinq points mille
autres façons ça changerait moi je
calcule plus en en plus qu'en nombre de
points qui je sais qu'à partir de
maintenant s'ils marquent 3 c'est bien
mark ii et demi ça peut passer
s'ils gagnent maintenant trois nuls
peuvent peut-être passé
deux nuls une victoire
6 nuls maintenant pareil faudra voir au
cas par cas mais il n'est pas du tout
éliminer de la course surtout qui peut
doubler les blancs maxime
pourquoi les punto chambre et en rouge
parce que ça peut être des faiblesses
ils peuvent être touchées un jour par le
fou ou par l'adam ça peut être un peu le
défaut de la position
cette partie elle est loin d'être
terminée donc non maxime il est bien
après c'est sûr que perdre ce serait
éliminatoire mais il peut pas perdre là
surtout qu'à tout un tas de gaillac
maxime peut battre après
c'est à quoi
avoir deux fois de suite et blanc
parma
la prochaine fois que fabiano et maxime
gagne et c'est même pas sûr qu'il faut
par contre ils roulent déjà
ces deux pour ça qu'il faut c'est de
faire dame prend des 5 1
m super à maxime ou là comme pas du tout
hein
un tour d un je pense pas mais tour à
des 1
ce qui est sûr c'est chiant il est déjà
foutu un
sachet quirion et déjà foutu
ce qui a vraiment terrible déjà éliminés
ou presque depuis le tournoi non mais
c'est obligatoire c'est un des autres
défauts des systèmes des troncs à des
chèques c'est que tu es obligé de rester
jusqu'au bout même pour les amateurs
d'air france tuée à jouer un tour à tour
joué le jeu jusqu'au bout même même si
tu es dans la panade et c'est un peu
relou
mon parti parti pour le mans qui se tend
qui temporise beaucoup quand même
on est déjà une heure et demie de jeu il
se passe pas grand chose
maxime la
prépa et pas rentrer je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont espéré
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont espéré avoir
mais clairement à
ce que maxime à spa à voir il l'a pas il
n'a pas obtenu
sais pas si je peux pas dire si bas
qu'il a aidé pour eux
pour la prépa ici
mais clairement si madame anne on peut
on en est sûr à 100% si ya pas eu de
bluff de réflexion quoi que ce soit
maxime clairement
soit il sépare appelé soit il n'a pas
obtenu ce qu'il voulait soit il s'est
fait surprendre
un bac et à reagan en bas qui est au
pakistan mais
mais il peut aider du bas qui ce temps
ils à ces machines il a le téléphone il
a tout un
après maxime c'est sûr qu'il va essayé
de la jouer le plus longtemps possible
ici avec les blancs
on va voir
1 et doit il doit il doit presser le
plus longtemps possible de ses joueurs
le hâle est le plus fort sur l'échiquier
ici maxime ils se cassent la tête pour
réussir à trouver une position il va y
avoir de la vie un
gars bien à fibrek sans wayne alors au
pakistan ils sont en train de tester la
cij est un
nous on installe à 5 g ici le bac il en
a déjà une technologie d'avant st
on peut qu'on peut exploiter avec le bac
iphone
dans la finale nom maxime l'aï regardé
ce qui fait tour c'est un pour taper le
pion c7 qu'est ce que ça donne après
tours 8 pour preuve en fut prend des
cinq qu'on a vu ce qu'ils jouent pour
dames des cats damas est et ils
cherchent peut-être une une troisième
voie mais il essaye de
[Musique]
de trouver la position la plus gênante 1
connais un peu le langage corporel de
maxime maintenant depuis le temps qu'on
connaît le marlou et on sait que là il
n'a pas la position idéale mais un façon
la voix sur l'échiquier mais
c'est lui le plus fort shirov peut faire
des erreurs c'est pas un ordi en face
comme on le disait il a aussi lâches qui
joue 49 ans
c'est quand même pas rien et on est déjà
la huitième ronde le tournoi éreintant
donc maxime doit doit mettre pression 1
lorsqu'il tours en c1
c'est ça il a mis la torah en c1
donc ils menacent de prendre ces 7 est
ce qu'on avait vu ici c'est que c'était
tour f8 l'idée des noirs pour attaquer
la dame et si la dame prend ses sept
pouvoir prendre en jean pour dévier la
tour sûr qu'on avait imaginé dam des
quatre qui n'est pas le seul coup tour
pro 1 tourcoing moment pour dévier et h
6 pour éviter donc beaucoup de variantes
1 tour 8 matches
sûr qu'on avait vu damas est on est on
avait regardé un peu fou prend des cinq
mais peut-être ça du tour d un ici
peut-être c'est l'idée de maxime
c6 dame prend 1 6 ess a ses avantages
donc ça voudrait dire que sur damas est
il faut jouer dame c8
et peut-être qu'il veut décision de
condé six tours 7
il tapait vii et surtour 17 il peut
faire [ __ ] henri vii est fou et 6 ça
peut être une variante qui gagne
à l'ail encore dames c'est un terrible
m'en faudrait tours 8 ça gagne
donc ça va vendre ça pourrait être ça
soit tous les feux huit dames des quatre
tours prend crise admettons h6 pour
éviter les matchs du couloir et damas
est et ça ça peut être un avantage
fou des cinq tours d un qui part et
chiant et dams et 8 des six
duels tout reprendre des six tours 7
food et 5 pour couvrir
et c'est un truc en fait à ses forces et
vous prend des cinq tours prend des cinq
tours france et cette dame e6
est peut-être que les noirs réussissent
à faire d'euros en force
bref ouais tour f 2,8 jouer tempo dam
des cats la vente est quasi forcée comme
je vous ai dit
tout reprendre ça va être jouée tout
reprendre 1 h 6
tours c'est non damas cette
dame c'est 8
mais là il ya aussi dame c5 qui est
envisageable
protège le pion prépare tour cette
dame 17 tours 7 d'amd si c'est hyper
chose ça encore
ça tient peut-être de justesse
mais là j'ai la turbine est pour m'aider
ok ça a l'air de tenir de justesse de
partout en fait pour les noirs mais il
faut trouver tous les coups précis 1
s'il se trompe sur un seul coup shirov
s'est perdue je pense
si shirov trouvent les coups ça va être
nul facile ouais ça je suis d'accord
plus facile maxima pas
maxime l'a pas mis dans une position
c'est des coups si difficile la
difficulté là c'est la précision et ne
pas se planter
c'est combien je me suis mal exprimé
en fait c'est des coups simples la
difficulté c'est qu'il ya d'autres coups
simples qui marchent pas
t'as pas un coup vraiment difficile en
soi
mais le truc c'est qu'il ya une
multitude de coups simples et dans ses
coups simples il ya des défauts amis
entre guillemets
à les fuir ou c'est déjà terminé un
cavalier aussi ce qui est presque huit
heures
donc tout reprend un jouet de la part de
shirov
fait c'est des coups simples mais pas
forcé serait des coups simples et forcé
ce serait sûr qu'ils les trouvent
là c'est des coups simples avec des
fausses direction
mois et firova gagner vraiment
facilement
en fait nous prenne pour un pitre sur
vous pensez vous qu'il va perdre ça
mais le jeu demande erreur en fait et
dire auxois tu l'as tiendrait avec les
noirs je sais pas mais j'ai l'impression
que vous
vous parlez dans le chat vous n'êtes pas
capable de faire une partie sans donner
une pièce en un et vous avez
l'impression que c'est facile d'être
hyper précis
non en fait ça va lui s'il s'arrête
quand on voit vos parties vous savez pas
mater avec un roi une dame
mais on a l'impression que faire une
partie parfaite sans erreur c'est facile
bref j'ai fait ces jours du tchad ben
ouais mais cette impression en fait
c'est que c'est dur en fait
c'est pas facile
et je vous ai expliqué pourquoi
c'est des coups ce simple mais il ya des
autres coûts qui paraît simple aussi et
qui marche pas il faut réussir dans
cette
dans cette petite jungle aa
bien tracter les problèmes à éviter les
petits pièges il ya beaucoup de petits
pièges facile il ya beaucoup de petites
tactiques pas très dur mais il y en a un
peu de partout et c'est ça qui donne la
difficulté de la drogue
les bars tout reprend 1 maxime qui s'est
levé
là aussi un ca sent que maxime il n'est
pas la grosse pression 1 il se lève et
tout ça on sent shirov vraiment
tranquille malheureusement
mais une différence quand c'est ton
métier vs aujourd'hui dimanche ça veut
pas dire que c'est facile
ça me fait penser au foot quand à des
gars qui ratent des un contre un contre
le goal à comment il arrêtait ça c'est
facile
mais il se trouve que nancy raté si on
vous dit que c'est pas facile c'est que
c'est pas facile en fait
faut arrêter de penser que tout est
simple genre par exemple hier le truc de
d'ailleurs c'était vraiment très très
très très très simple c'est est mille
fois plus simple que ça la position est
fière que d'ailleurs a perdu
j'ai l'impression qu'on oublie tout à
fait mais il ya la fatigue ya plein de
choses qui rentrent en jeu donc même les
trucs les plus simples il faut encore
les réaliser voilà c'était on était sûrs
du 2 3 % de chances de se tromper là on
est sur un truc quand même relativement
plus dur alors normalement il va réussir
mais s'est pas fait
chaque on a regardé combien on a
l'impression que c'était que des
premières lignes redit tout le temps
oui mais est ce que shirov est un joueur
du niveau des candidats
là on a affaire à des joueurs qui sont
retraités en fait fin faut comprendre
que shirov c'est pas un joueur
professionnel à proprement dire ca
retraité
s'est pas caruana c'est pas un top
mondial
est bon aux candidats vous rappelez
peut-être pas mais la partie dingli
rennes contre maxime ce quart à théding
irène c'était incroyable
c'était vraiment très très simple et la
partie great uk mme weil a aussi eu des
ratés dans des positions il doit pas y
en avoir
mille fois il l'a loupé une seule fois
aussi d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
après là où je suis d'accord c'est comme
les parties sont très longues c'est très
chiant d'attendre parce que tu attends
un jeune et un truc août à 1 % de
chances que sarah tête attend pendant
trois plombes
par chirac devait même pas faire le
tournoi il s'est décidé la veille
exactement robin side il devait pas le
faire il ya des places qui ont été
laissées vacantes de par les annulations
et donc c'est comme ça qu'il s'est
retrouvé à jouer
face à un mec qui est retraités enfin il
vient vu jouer le tournoi en mode à
bages et à riga en même temps je viens
jouer dans ce qui par quoi
90% de chances gros quand même c'est pas
super dur je peux te je sais pas le
pourcentage je suis plus ou moins
d'accord avec toi bobby fischer 2 mais
ça reste 10% des fêtes
moi je mettrais plutôt 15 20 mai
en shirov on est sur un vrai vrai
retraités à 200% quoi le mec doit même
pas jouer tiens je mette un peu changé
de position pour un soir
sur un refuge sûr il veut même pas faire
les candidats je pense pas que j'ai
refait envie de faire les candidats mais
ça se peut que six qualifiés refuse la
place en fait
honnêtement s'il se qualifie je donnerai
plus de 50% de chances qu'ils refusent
la place
parce que
candidat chirac dont il ira pas mais
s'il y aller c'est un c'est une torture
sur les quatorze parties peuvent
vraiment finir
2 sur 14 quoi c'est vraiment possible
alireza ça se passe comment la position
à l'air absolument écrasante
ses cales de plus il faut juste être
précis mais ses cales de plus
une fois je suis le mec a patiemment
pour le temps il était debout en fait
est là pourquoi ils retombent shirov
barilla 1h02 encore
mais oui je comprends il c'est maxime
qui était debout désolé j'ai mal compris
la question
mais il recule y vérifie
et calexico nom alex enhco est plus fort
que celle enfin
y'a pas un pion prise en d5 et non parce
qu'après [ __ ] en dame prend dame prend
vous prend tout reprend il ya toujours
huit matches
d'où le courage 6 pour menacer fou prend
des cinq
dames à cette dame c'est 8 des six je
pense maxime il veut jouer ça
qualifié au candidat mais que tu y vas
pas que mais que tu vas la main dans le
slip en turquie se prendre un site
semble a commis ou c'est pas le genre de
la maison
non c'est plus
pour moi c'est plus le système de
qualification aux candidats qui est pas
terrible mais
[Musique]
c'est détourne temps tu donnes des
places aux candidats sur des tournois
loterie au lieu de faire des circuits à
l'année comme on en a souvent parlé de
faire des tours à l'enjeu tout un enjeu
tout au long de l'année etc
c'est plus un problème global
d'organisation du sport en fête
thank you quand même de loin sur la
toile peut être meilleur
ça veut dire que tu penses que si pete
sampras sort de sa retraite demain il
peut être meilleur qu'un joueur qui
étape 30 monde au tennis
en gros
un système similaire aux grandes
chansons où tu gagnes des points sur les
toits tout au long de l'année se sentent
plus adapté à ses deux seins plus
adaptée de deux savaient de l'enjeu dans
les tons à toute l'année donc c est plus
juste au niveau sportif est plus
intéressant au niveau public
c'est que magnus joue moins que les
autres puisqu'il ne doit pas se
qualifier pour les candidats il joue pas
les tournois qualificatifs mais je vous
d'autres tournois
on va voir ce qu'ils jouent et il joue
dam des six alors d'amd 6
c'était l'autre coût
auquel on avait pensé après on était
parti sur un chasseur d'âmes des six
jeunes c'est une belle casse pour la
dame on a très envie de la mettre là bas
la question c'est damas est
fou prend des seins qu'on avait vu tour
d un ici
et on avait pensé ces six daims prend
1,6 mais du coup là je mets la turbine
est il que tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
apparemment là dessus la torah 8
c'est l'idée dames 3 et 6
d4 quand même pour presser tour des huit
dames b6 elle ment d'une manière x ou y
ça doit être nul ça
on met clairement faut tenter damas sept
ans je pense
est fou des 5 fu dessin gamme des cinq
dames à six tours à
8o
sur cinq gagne pour les blancs
aussi maxime à il la passa shirov
hockey et ses turbines est en
cours 5 hyper dur
y perdurent comme vous
c'est terrible
oh ça c'est terrible
parce que tourcoing 6 et tour huit
matches et dames prendre 5 ces dames à 8
matt
aut
et donc ça veut dire que si max arrive
là il va peut-être la gagne c'est pas
sûr que ce soit gagnant mais ces
poussettes avec le pion à 5
rami 6 tours à huit tours 5 dames
derrière watch deux et on peut pas
prendre la dame nature tour huit matches
et on va gagner le pion b5 et la partie
avec
où ça ça peut être un trou dans la
raquette damas est fou des 5 fu prend
dame prend dame prend tour à 8 et tours
l e tour aux 5 enfin deux variantes
évolué
maxime peut la voir et shirov peut ne
pas la voir
donc ça veut dire que sur damas 7
il ya une couille pour shirov
5 trop dur non maximy peut la voir
en fait ça veut dire qu'il est obligé de
rentrer là dedans
mais ok ça ça joue un peu quand même
ça ça peut jouer quand même c'est loin
d'être simple pion à 5 est vraiment
dangereux
mais oui comme vous disiez dans le chat
c'est facile c'était facile de
comprendre que c'était plus sage si ce
que d'amd si sa cote de damas est fou
des cinq coups des cinq dames des cinq
tours damas six tours à huit tours 5
maxime il peut la voir ansa
huit alertes green adam donc il va
forcément trouvé ça chelou
alors vers le truc c'est que tu as la
variante que j'ai de base de basta tour
d un tour à 8 ici
la collecte wa robin
de basta ça
et du coup vous prend d'apprendre dame
prend tour à 8 tours 5 c'est tellement
pas schématique comme truc c est rare
comme coup
faim ce thème de jouer sur le match de
couloirs du couloir il arrive souvent
mais tour 5 il est pas
j'en ai rarement vu des coûts de tours
comme ça
il est vrai facile mais maxime peut la
voir
et sur l'échec
2 et ouais il n'y a pas de coups en fait
un tour sans que grâce à leur dirai je
n'aurais pas eu pour autant que j'aurais
raté ok il ya un show tout je le trouve
en partie évidemment enfin je peux
trouver
je peux trouver mais le plus probable
c'est que j'ai pas
donc du coup ça vire sur damas 7 ckoi le
coup de shirov
mais chirac va le voir en fait shirov
une fois qui va arriver là il va le voir
mais il est peut-être obligé de partir
là dedans quand même il va devoir
défendre ça
après c'est pas dit que ce soit gagnant
pour les blancs pour autant
ses paillettes soit gagnant pour les
blancs
fois huit pages x 8 ces concessions déjà
sa ligne et celle de leur dîme après
terme à 6 ch 6 ce que je suis en train
de me demander est-ce que ça c'est si
grave
ou alors shirov a vu tour 5 et il pense
que ça ça passe
je n'aurais pas jouer avec les noirs je
serai pas rentrer là-dedans
volontairement après une fois que tu y
étais obligé de la jouer et c'est
peut-être pas si grave
ouais
c'est peut-être pas si grave
de toute façon tours à huit il va le
voir à ce moment là une fois que il ya
fou prend des cinq dames prendre si même
s'il avait pas vu ici tu le vois à tour
à 8h05 par contre
manqué
une position qui peut arriver mais c'est
assez chiant
ça c'est très relou pour les noirs
14.5
jarret pas les noirs l'option est trop
dangereux mais bon
on va réussir à le chopper
peut-être c'est drôle quand même on
n'arrive pas
à remettre la marche avant à un tempo
près on n'a pas le temps de mettre la
marche avant
j'ai l'impression que ces bols pour
shirov mais peut-être si la vue
fille rousse à chiquer réfléchir ou est
ce qui prend en direct en fuite est ce
qu il intercale un b 4 il a raison
car maxime réfléchit plus aujourd'hui
que les autres jours ça prouve bien que
la défense de chirac et qualitative
je pense pas qu'il ait vu non plus mais
non mais il a pu voir
parce que max a una non plus c'est dur à
dire
carmax réfléchi
au sens grec temps beaucoup d'entre eux
ça en direct ça sent pas le bon coup
en mai a pas vraiment de marion qui
gagne il ya un truc qui fait qu'il peut
jouer une variante qui en fait marche
pas vraiment non plus de justesse mais
qui semble faire mal mais qui fait pas
mal donc à rien qu'ils gagnent là en
fait personne n'a jamais dit que ça
gagner un
carrément
kamerhe flou
le truc c'est que rennes on damas est
je pense il devrait y va quand même
partir pour
corporels très positif maxime
aujourd'hui
il n'a pas le langage corporel le plus
positif
de la semaine
qui au tournant il est seul
on doit décrire ce genre de calcul sur
le papier n'ont
pas pas le droit d'écrire à décrire
tu dois tout faire de tête
à voir en tout cas il est concentré
maxime
sauce déjà fait pour ça oui il a déjà
été annoncé père enfin donné perdant par
l'arbitré ce qu'il écrivait sur sa
feuille
leschi maxime
allais il va nous claquer un coup
envoyé à damman à cette regardez-moi ça
non dames trois
dames e3
il part pour h6
d'un mécène j'imagine d'un prince est en
france est fou prend des cinq prend des
cinq tours prend des cinq tours prend
ses sept tours d un rouage de tours d2
non
à
six tours d1 alors peut-être
ok il va faire acheter ce tour des reins
ça empêche dame c5 et dames 5
non il va jouer ça comme ça
ayez de faire quelque chose
b4 des dames à 7 ou d'aidé s'il a des
trucs quoi
il va essayer il a dû comprendre que le
damas damas si c'était drôle
mais la tête faire pousser 8 en fait et
repartir de ce côté avec le fou
maintenant à tour c'est si ça il va
faire sa maxime
il va faire six dames b dordain
mais tours d 1 h 6 tours de rein d'un
bep cap des 6
cd tour des cas tu vas par là bas
se passe des choses encore
il se passe en
zain
est ce qu'il veut faire maxime
anton guirao dit qu'il est bien contre
rien de fait un
après c'est cool le fou est bloqué en b1
mais bon ça avantage mais c'est pas
gagné encore
youtube of ponkrashov
l'habitude goff attention est bien guéri
championnat de russie s'ils commencent à
mettre les point ça peut faire mal
macho
peut être dangereux aussi suivant ce qui
fait maintenant sarah nailloux
pas que ça à perdre avec les blancs
pas envie de le voir revenir you
tabatabai contre alex nkossa ça peut
être important pour maxime
et bien finie man
party ne vois vraiment rien fait du
tournoi
cheyrou y réfléchit encore sur la prise
en fuite
il obtient pas grand chose depuis le
début du tournoi
je pensais qu'il serait beaucoup plus
dangereux mais apparemment comme le
disait vanilla vraiment abandonné les
échecs face à abandonner le travail
qu'il faut faire pour être joueurs
provale et on repart sur une trois
minutes de pub
je l'entends sec c'est bien enfin c'est
cool mais là c'est normal à 4 honte de
la fin qu'on reste sur l'avant du
tournoi j'espère qu'il ya une bulle bien
évidemment mais
il est plus dans la course
malheureusement
il a joué 6
sakic
maxime images ou et m tour d arrêt
donc c'était bien ça l'idée il a dû voir
le damas est il a dû tout voir il a dû
voir le tour 5 et il a dû bien jugé la
finale en réalité
et du coup il part pour ça qui est la
position qui laisse les erreurs à shirov
je trouve que c'est vraiment bien joué
de la part de maxime est le damas est
n'était pas suffisant
et donc ils laissent des erreurs
possibles
côté noir
il n'y a pas vraiment de coup avec les
noirs quasi tu as envie de faire roy
fuite roy g8
super déjà ses sept
ouais c'est chiant vrai
en vrai c'est chiant
c'est sûr que ça va pour les noirs mais
c'est chiant à vrai dire
annuler tous mènent pas annuler du tout
en fait
sumann pas un nul à vrai dire
je me demande si j'aurais pas tours à
huit personnes
peut-être un peu trop peu le travail
bien
très chiant cette position est en fête
a maintenant il ya le tour à 8 qui
fonctionne
il a joué fous ces huit
hockey son idée sur tours c1 c'est fou
bessette je pense
damas est fou des cinq
est retombé dans le truc comme ça
annonce des cinq dames des cinq dames c7
et la torah 8 toujours avec cette même
idée rang vrai je pense qu'il va réussir
à marle ajouté
et sur damas satisfait comment
les parents f5 corsair
qui est chaud aussi [ __ ]
fr hyper gaffe en fait
si on y va trop fort on peut se faire
contrer
ok c'est pas évident
évident
mdk peut être une idée aurait aussi fait
il veut peut-être placé son fou par là
et puis avoir le deux fous qui n'est pas
très utile et après envoyé dam des
quatre pour aller essayer de choper à 5
c'est manu soit magnus avait gagné
contre firoud déjà avec la même variante
robin side on payait pas il avait
bifurqué évidemment au 17e 18e coup il
n'était pas rentré exactement dans le
même truc mais c'était la même structure
et les mêmes pièces et il avait gagné la
finale
mais pour ça que c'est pas mal joué le
coup c'est vite fait f5
et il joue assez vite shirov aussi
contre maxime il a raison de le faire je
trouve que je suis revenir tellement
bien sa partie
c'est moins pedneault que ce que maxime
a joué avant un shirov clairement sa
chique à lyon c'était vraiment le bo
péno
ça joue côté sa chique à rien après ce
que vous dites lordier mais pas trop car
lé premier fuite il préférait intercalé
b4 avant ali reza a pris
donc sa chique ya rien ouais il n'a
jamais été menaçant de quoi que ce soit
shirov c'est un ex top mondial c'est
quand même différent
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas le
même calibre de voir
il reprend du fonds au fisc il n'aime
pas du tout naturel
pour ce héros maxime
dont qui menacent tour c6 et du coup ici
le coup ça semble être fourbe et 7
retours pour menacer fou prend des 5
et surtour c5 du coup la tour serait mal
placé parce qu elle obstrue le passage
de la dame
ça sent la drogue
l'adroit effectivement
ça pue la droite net on va voir enfin
vous êtes toujours tellement sûr de ce
que vous dites c'est incroyable vous
n'êtes jamais dans la nuance
fauvez cette dame c'est cinq ans il faut
prendre les 5 1
ont des cinq ans prend des cinq dames
procès sept
ça a l'air bien d'euros 1
mais bon
bessette il va peut-être jouer autre
chose
peut-être fait retour des 1 et chercher
autre chose en maxime
mais où ils sont pas la sérénité côté
max
est ce que je sens
les ficelles damas 7d 5d cinq dames des
cinq courses et 7
pour essayer de doubler mais le truc
c'est que le roi blanc se retrouve bien
esseulé
ça peut être dangereux en réalité pour
maxime
je pense qu'il va remettre le flamber 7
c'est assez logique
racing métro n'a par contre pas regretté
par le feu l'ouverture parce qu'il ya
sûrement rien rater ça c'est sûr
c'est le problème entre guillemets des
échecs de haut niveau c'est que beaucoup
jouent dans l'ouverture et si tu rates
ton shot
mais sur at-on choc dans l'ouverture et
bien après t'as plus rien
bon
on va voir fu bessette qui paraît
logique
shirov c'est vraiment un colosse 1 pour
si vous l'avez déjà vu henry en réel ça
se voit là la caméra un maxime il paraît
pas petit globalement face à ses autres
adversaires mais là shirov on sent qu'il
ya 3 maxime en phase 1
combien de guy pour stopper un shirov à
mon avis beaucoup
qui gagne le combat titanal
sur un julien sire off contre 110 geek
qui gagna je pense et on s'y raffin je
vois pas les guérit
plaqué quoi
je vais essayer bêtise mais là sont des
recherches devenu l'appareil fait
victoire pour qu'il y ait moins deux
nuls maintenant on n'y a pas moyen
y'a pas moyen de bien le faire
thaçi rohff qui fait ça gagne
malheureusement il aura fait nul il a
fait nul qui il a fait nul et s'y
tiennent qu'à un fil rouge là et peut
faire nul et si bienne caf cheyrou déjà
mvele
ce qui vous me l'accorderez serez un
triptyque assez sympa
c'est quand même solide ces trois
joueurs du top mondial et trois nuls
dont deux avec
avec les noirs c'est quand même très
solide
s'il réussit à faire trois nuls comme ça
c'est quand même ultra solide de sa part
surtout qu'il a fait un gros début de
tour donc il aura battu les plots et il
peut se présenter contre les tops
mondiaux
après le prime pour lui c'est quand il
va se prendre flotteurs descendant sur
sur caruana s'ils gagnent
n'a pas forcément le plus
intéressant il fait foot 17
ha ok donc il ya clairement moyen de le
battre
maxime est content de fou 17 je crois
je crois que
content de ce coup
parce que
visuellement je sais pas le coup paraît
pas top
ça se voit qu'il est content et je crois
que tomber cette
salle déprimé
pouvait 7
déprimant mais fou 17 fait plaisir
tu sens que ça fait plaise pas ce que
ça donne du de la vie un peu dans la
position notamment un coup comme dame g3
est peut-être possible dame prend elle
prend tour c8 et jouer cette finale avec
le roi qui monte c'est déjà une option
après les noirs donne l'impression
d'arriver juste à temps donc ça se fait
pas mais ça peut être une idée
tout cas maxime ça se voit qu'ils
étaient contents de voir ce coup
vous 17
ouais alors après qu'elle ait l'idée de
shirov c'est sûrement de mettre la tour
en 8es de s'activer 1
la dame c5 aussi qui peut jouer d'un
prince et 5 pour penser 5 pour ces huit
essais de jouer cette finale
peut-être anticipé en jouant f
4l tour huit dames ces cinq noms
vous 17 s'enlève la pression est sur des
cinq sur damas at il veut quoi il veut
tours 8
dans le conte ses sept tours un
temps reprend le gendarme français cet
intéressant
ça peut donner du jeu de contres aussi à
shirov mais c'est eux
c'est étonnant tout de même
je trouve que non
je trouve que c'est assez étonnant de
ne pas être revenu en baisse est tout de
même mais bon
on prend ça va un petit peu joué
du coup ça va un petit peu joué
v coup un fou 17 c'est un coût qui fait
jouer quoi
alors s pour une raison x ou y
shirov se dit que c'est pas mal de jouer
le contre
pareil quand même je
akira
un très clairement
il n'y a pas assez de vie dans la
position mais après
ces cinq ça va rien donner prise pour qu
est le roi bien
d'un griche ali reza alors voilà jeté un
oeil
et quick épreuves tour premières fuites
des 4 et e4
ont qu à l idée c'était france et 5
c'est pas de reprendre f3 directement
c'est de jouer cavalier ou 5
alors sur ce qui a eu un instinct qui a
peut-être qu'il prend 1,5 fou prend
cavaliers prend et trois fuites
sûrement de jouer l'autre cavaler ans le
5 et essayer de mettre une attaque de
maths comme ça ballon qui allait prendre
un fou prend des inquiets des sept dames
bouge fou prend qui comprend qu'ils
allaient prendre dame prend et tour
franck ex comme ça va ça l'art est
complètement terminée un
salaire d'être complètement gagnant pour
ali reza
ça a l'air d'être complètement gagnant
pour ali reza bonne façon une fois que
tu as fait puis on prendra comme une
tournette de plus à ce moment là
après qui peut avoir une idée
de damas mais il a même pas d'âme g5 et
sur dame g6 qui avait pris la fuite il
touche la dame donc y'a jamais de fouet
f3c dada c'est d'être ça pour les noirs
c'est l'équivalent de pièces net de -
avec les toutes les pièces blanches qui
sortent
assez terrible il peut prendre un coup
aujourd'hui avoir la tête qui fait
hier de complètement suez sa chique et
riant c'est vraiment une partie de merde
terrible
non c'est terrible pour c'est chiant
il est tout petit rhénan ça se voit
et maxime et maxime maxi maxi ouais
c'est la première partie où il réfléchit
beaucoup et où
il connaît l'importance de la partie 1
il sait qu'avec son style il faut il
faut marquer il faut score avec les
blancs
hélas aujourd'hui ça lui échappe
après caruana savait pas l'air de
revenir au caruana grande et lui s'il
est vraiment venu venu chercher là nul
vite yougov ça peut gagner
la position est belle pour lui
la grosse domination ici
et s'ils tiennent qu'à
s'étant dax contre un retraité
du peuple ça c'est des joueurs forts
éviter qu'ils reviennent
bof c'est ultra tendues
et de cf guirao aguilar au pourrait
monter mais kerharo ça peut être un
semis pedneault quand même
peut être une bonne nouvelle match où il
presse avec les blancs n'est ce pas sûr
qu'ils gagnent sarine solide
et des âges pivots rouge qu ils ont déjà
fait nulle âme et je vous ai dit a pas
grand monde qui va remonter à mon avis
il ya trop de serrure prête que tahri
s'est aussi drôle
en fait ils prient font jamais all in en
fait ces plots vs plots n'y a jamais de
aline
on prend ça à notre avantage mais je
veux dire par là que ces plots vs plots
quoi
et du coup ils font coup de mieux
pearl où il va y avoir trois quatre gars
qui vont gagner mais peut-être sur un
multitude d'échiquier il va y avoir 80 %
de draw
l'autre plots vs pleutre plots ouais
mais ça ferait les affaires de maxime au
classement
après attention à shirov au départage
quand même
qui va au bout d'un moment on se
retrouve avec un meilleur des partages
que maxime
qui pourrait se retrouver car meilleur
des partages de maxime
alors ils étaient loin sur un fil avait
vraiment des partages pourri non qu'il
est quand même assez tranquille maxime
la rényon qu'il lâche une pièce en un
est vraiment complètement hors forme
j'ai du mal à y croire
ouais non mais il a du jeu
l'on vous disait qu'il était gagnant il
est loin d'être gagnant un sage ou un
mail vannes il est vraiment pas dans ce
tournoi il pourra pas remonter
et fille ruth jacky à trouver et fierro
déjà en revanche ça va plier à dos le
tour nadeau
ça peut plier le
le tournoi je suis en train de regarder
ceux qui sont sur l'étape derrière
jacques rives auront jusqu'au qui a fait
nul prêtres qu'ils vont faire
probablement nulle joue bierhoff
faible of
même pas comment le trouvez talent il a
un petit lots contre petrosyan
ça peut aussi faire de la drau
ya beaucoup de joueurs solides si vous
les uns contre les autres
c'est possible ça fasse quasi fuld
roquois
magnifique
je cachais 20 ans
et des partages s'est basé sur les
points qu'on marquait tes adversaires
mais c'est bon pour filles on abat fièr
où
il pourrait se retrouver avec un point
en avance sur le deuxième et même pas un
gros groupe derrière donc quand il peut
vraiment y aller avec trois nuls zéro
plus tu commence fort dans le tour à mes
yeux meilleur et on départage
généralement oui c'est pour ça que les
gens qui reviennent de derrière il doit
avoir des moins bons des partages
sur la multitude de gars quatre et demi
a tellement de serrure
tabata bel et bien le cinéma ni la 4e
maxime ses adversaires du début ils ont
fait des bonds tournoi
hyper positif
adam g 3 max
donc ça me prend et prend
pour ses 8
il va peut-être tentés tour f1 droit est
fluide et
6,6 des sites en france et 7 ouais mais
ça c'est drôle chez drouot ça
j'aurais jamais tenté le damas est
sûr que ça va gagner la partie
la partie de sa chique erian est assez
assez ridicule honnêtement
il va prendre perdants après quinze
coups quand même étonnant 1 place aux
candidats à table le 1 8e ronde ça prend
15 cours
c'est la partie est déjà terminée
si roux qui va qui va faire mal
ça va changez va avoir deux tours est un
fou contre une dame
sarah guérisseur ans la partie de maxime
aujourd'hui qui est déterminante
ferroudja en fait il est quasiment
qualifié on va le suivre évidemment on
le suit autant que maxime en réalité
hier je % à passer plus de temps et sur
la partie d'alireza au final
voilà là il a une partie facile il la
gagne il va avoir un point en avance
ça veut dire que si maxime fait si on
pense que maxime skalli fake 2 sur 3
c'est à dire que vrai que un sur trois
pour ali
jaouen calciques asie khalifa
on chante sur bon on l'a montré il n'y a
pas très longtemps capsule au pire on
leur fera avec on refera la fin de la
partie on fera sûrement cette partie
avec fabre ce soir
est-ce que je vais gérer parce qu'il
peut clairement gagné une autre deux
autres places anormal a tu veux juste
qualifié
firoud là tu lui dis tu prends trois
nullissime tout de suite hein
et dames francs
si on prend un tour s'est vite j'ai
quatre mares l'om et mont-royal fui
trois sets 3 des 6
après ce qui peut vouloir frauder un
bref wef
3,7 des six
amis a toujours que je comprends
et surtout reprend fou et surtout on
voit ici foulée 7
je ne vois pas comment il peut vouloir
gagner ça vous dit que c'était la
première ligne de l'ordi donc je vous
dis qu'il ya peut-être du danger mais je
vois pas le danger en fait je vois pas
le plan
et j'avais tenté tour f1 mais bon
endroit et suit des 6 7 6 si on ne prend
plus prendre il peut vouloir ça mais
c'est complètement nul
pas quand même un dégât ni candidat qui
avait juste posant nue le cheval est un
qui la poussait c'était carré akin je
pense le truc ce qu'il était
complètement gagnant
caruana l'a fait aussi ouais mais bon il
n'a pas poussé de base c'est jusqu'à
près quant à +4 tu gagnes mais tu
pousses pas de base faut se rappeler de
la partie quand même
si l'autre en voit trop et qu'ils
s'envoient en l'air tue le termine mais
20 prend citoyen ça paraît vraiment trop
drôle
l'intérêt a refusé les est gelée changé
d'âme non je pense dans le projet trois
tours s'est vite c'est le seul coup pour
faire nul mais c'est pas c'est pas que
c'est logique c'est que c'est archi
logique après ce que maxime peut voir
tour série 3 et faiseurs ou avait fui
tour e 1 pour bloquer mais bon tour de
huit
tours troyes tours prend trois rois
prend trois rois aux sept rois des cas
trois des six et c'est pas du tout la
même que celle qu'a eue magnus parce que
là le pion dessin qui t'empêche
d'accéder aux pions derrière
hemani et maxime c'est pas du tout sûr
qu'ils jouent ensemble parce qu'il reste
plus que trois parties et caruana il a
joué ni fille rooney mvl donc peut-être
que s'il fait flotteurs montant et
montrent plutôt sur fear où ça dépend
des couleurs ça dépend de beaucoup de
choses mais ça se peut que maxime je
vous avais contre caruana
avant cette finale essayer de passer
comme ça
mais bon non mais là normalement ces
finales là
je pense qu'il essayait de faire un g4
un jour mettre le four f5 proposer les
changes m en zoulou hangar en transe et
mais même un setup comme ça
même avec tous les temps d'attendre du
monde tu vas jamais gagné
ce que le roi il vient comme ça et
l'option il contrôle sept cases donc
même ça c'est complètement nul
même si tu prends pas fait même ça c'est
complètement nul
ouais donc cette finale à halle doit pas
gagné non plus
je vois pas de scénario en fait pour
maxime
sajoo le gain quoi
un joueur scénario
s'y prend pas ça avant ça je ne vois pas
dans quel monde tu prends pas en fait
maxime c2c de rejouer plus demain
important c'est de rejouer plots demain
en fait
les férus du coup est-ce que ça gagne
c'est la position qu'on a vu c'est
complètement terminée
c'est complètement termine à dos
3h et qui rend il a remis le sac en
bandoulière
je pense qu'il a un stand alfa échec sa
chique et riant
il rend la monnaie le frérot
terrible
complètement terminé 1 j'en prends fouet
f4
l'avantagent max matériel est trop
important
il va un peu joué et mer
là
allez un trop grand retard matériel 1 ça
fait un
tour dames cavaliers contre contre dames
la seule chance pour les noirs c'est
d'essayer d'envoyer sur le roi mais
normalement
les clients sur le sur le stand
en firent ou là les vallées facile la
game
et shirov ça va échanger et tour
s'éviterait
riboud
cicas rouler en boule dans un coin de la
salle ar il est vraiment pas bien sa
chute hier et maxime ça va pas passer
non plus
malheureusement ces gie gadreau donc ali
ali
ali reza c'est une bonne un bon résultat
pour lui après un si on parle d'un point
de vue individuel
skalli rezaï va avoir un point d'avancé
complet sur tous les poursuivants à
lille est vraiment sûr que trois nuls
lui suffisent
alireza il est sûr que trois ils lui
suffisent en fait c'est impossible
autrement
ça passe à l'oeuf à vie a annoncé
toujours important de gagner toi c'est
plus important les parties des joueurs
français que la plaie partie des
adversaires
by rezala s'ils gagnent aujourd'hui il
est à 95 % au candidat
il va avoir deux noir un blanc fou qu'il
fasse 3 nuls y a que 1 fabiano ou quoi
maintenant il est tellement fort
je suis les deux joueurs français yark
- il y en a déjà un qui y est j'en ai
déjà un quasiment assurée c'est gagner
aujourd'hui
sache et connaisse ses dauphins plus aux
afro non ça changerait incarner un ou
deux pour moi ça change rien
en fait s'ils gagnent en sac en disant
le chatte ils ont ils ont leur destin
entre les mains les français on n'a pas
besoin de compter sur les résultats des
autres surtout que c'est pas forcément
fabiano le premier danger l'armée des
plots est plus forte en fait
plus de proposer nul maintenant
voilà j'ai du mal à imaginer poussette
de maximin
et maxi avoir son destin entre les mains
je suis quasiment sûr armes et des plots
fait beaucoup de nuls
tu as raison qu'elle je vais juste dire
qu'il ya là sans le sûr de gagner mvl
sûr de faire nul
bien sûr qu'ils apprennent encore
converti a quand même pu espérer faire
une gaffe même salle échiquier où il ya
certes eu 68 familles
bah ouais pourquoi failli plus qu'un
autre en fait
ballaigues de l'himalaya bal avec de
fabi
1% ce qui est beaucoup d'euros 1
ça
ou pas qui la force à celle là je peux
être acceptée la drau un
peu regardé un des scissions prend tour
d un
n'y a pas de monde où ça passe même un
tour c6 ou des cinq tours secours
tourisme et 7
au pied et prend b2 il va rien se passer
va pas tenter le diable quoi elle diable
sur ce qui a poussé si c'est tout
reprend g2 qui peut arriver
table quatre victimes qu'à fouet fred
faut éviter qu'il ya une armée de plots
qui monte genre six ou sept victoires de
plo ce serait gênant
je l'avais dona erie hier ensuite ça
passerait pas oui mais comparé comme
d'habitude l'incomparable évidemment
hier firoud déjà il avait un avantage
dans la finale il a poussé avec un pion
de plus la finale était nul mais il y
avait un pion plus
ici maxime il est pas mieux a dit reza
il était mieux hier
la maxime il n'est pas mieux
c'est ça la grosse différence
donc il faut pas trop là il va partir
pour ce truc là
et essayer de jouer pour le pion là bas
je veux tenter ça
mais bon c'est pas du tout la même que
celle que magnus avait eu contre firoud
déjà parce que le roi est beaucoup plus
proche pour les noirs des pions
et la structure blanche est pas aussi
bonnes parce qu'il avait les pions
propre et la maxime il n'a pas les pions
propre sur gk tuera g5 instantané
il a gagné mais non mais vous êtes
stupides parfois dans le chat c'est pas
possible hier ali riza la position était
nul mais il avait un pion de plus
c'est pas du tout pareil en fait une
position égal avec chance réciproque est
là c'est vraiment égale égal
5 % de chances de gain exactement entre
5 et 10 suivant également vous l'avez
regardé
c'est pas du tout la même c'est pas du
tout de même scénario
s'est pas dû le même scénario
ce
que tu penses que jean-christophe
dangereux candidats way jean-christophe
peut être très dangereux candidat
mais mika ou qui a analysé la partie 10
son adversaire jeu n'importe comment et
qui s'est planté dans une erreur de
calcul s'est inversée à jouer n'importe
quoi mais hier
c'est rarissime
les gens comprennent pas que la
pollution peut être nul mais pas égal à
l'évaluation est ce c'est un truc genre
du mal à comprendre
mais là en fait en poussant tu peux
perdre aussi avec les blancs c'est ça
aussi il faut comprendre
là il ya 2 % de chances de gain de
chaque côté c'est pas du tout comme hier
fairway fuite
c'est un con abl en fait
mais je le prends en compte pascal non
en fait je vais de banat forces afin
soit tu le fais exprès soit tu comprends
pas meilleur c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible de ne pas comprendre
enfin ce jeu c'est pas assez parlé sans
comprendre de quoi tu parles de quoi
espèrent qu'il a joué un petit peu
maxime mais bon il faut faire attention
que ça se retourne pas
qu'il va tenter ça
ok intéressant alors cédé pour prend
tour c'est un rêve de fou c'est si ça
semble être la ligne pour les noirs
veut essayer de bloquer droit avec tours
e6 ok ça c'est l'idée de maxime
c'est intéressant parce qu au moins ça
peut ça peut pousser une erreur
ok maxime qui tente le truc le plus
intéressant
pour gagner
ces 5 fu des cinq
c4
wave de hockey
il ya trouvé un truc qu'il peut y avoir
des erreurs
ça doit pas être gagnant du tout hein il
doit rien à voir mais il peut y avoir
des erreurs ici
tiers pour ça en fait
ok
doit tenter ça
va-t-en ça parce que ça peut être une
chance
la paroisse des 6 es tu
étais un peu mieux avec les blancs et il
doit penser qu' il va pas se tromper
vous faire gaffe à ce que tu peux perdre
à 5 être trouvée mal
ouais il décide de prendre des petits
des petits riches mais contrôlé
façon il doit penser que dans le tournoi
c'est peut-être le sait pas forcément
c'est être un des derniers joueurs
vraiment faible contre qui joue maxime
nom qu'il a raison de l'ajout et
surinfection aujourd'hui finale ouais
mais il ya la fatigue qui peut qui peut
rentrer en compte 1 on l'a vu ça hier ça
c'est vrai
caruana grande île us sarre est
complètement drôle
ça reste complètement nul parfois vous
dites qui a poussé caruana c'est très
égal après il est plus fort il peut
essayer de la gagner
yougov qui va gagner
attention joueur russe champion de
russie en titre
ouais les six pieds
nkt ici pianca prend tous les risques
pour essayer de gagner les noirs pour
revenir il cravache et de cf ghirard
hossa aurait un joueur espagnol qui
revient
macho lui je pense qu'il peut être
dangereux mais sarine et hyper solide
en quoi il ya des gars qui reviennent y
en a d'autres qui reviennent pas
prête que qui devrait pas réussir à
battre paris
beaucoup de draw quand même derrière
et maxime qui tendent tous
hyper aujourd'hui aronian c'est
incroyable
alors qu'ils donnent gagnant pour les
noirs m et aronian ça sent la fin de
carrière pour le genre arménien s y perd
aujourd'hui contre ylmaz c'est terrible
parce que il va c'est pop l'oim
harel et les bons qui peut
qui petit à petit rejoindre hikaru
nakamura au classement elo attention
et alireza du coup c'était juste
complètement gagnant
webb à l'âge qui passe à peut-être fans
carrière et là tu es pris le petit
chèque de signes que field et puis
maintenant ils arrêtent jolie
alireza ça va gagner il ya aucun doute
la position est gagnante
c'est la bonne nouvelle
est allé maxime peut-être petite chance
bien trouvé le tour des 1
il hésite entre ces cinq essais des
j'imagine
shirov
en cas
donc
c'est des torrents
or c'est un rêve de fou c'est 8
ouais je pense
va partir
tant du temps j'ai encore des vies 3,7
en g8 g5 nom
et le roi qui monte là bas ça va être
hyper dangereux je ne sais pas
ça peut être double tranchant et ça peut
être ça peut tourner double tranchant
on va voir
il a 50 ans
non mais t'as pas à bata si t'es pas
content juste eu déconnecte fin qu'est
ce que vous êtes relou sur le tchat
voilà c'est pas possible on essaye de
comprendre des positions d'échec on se
retrouve avec milliers de co2 de
questions qui reviennent mille fois par
jour c'est incroyable c'est compliqué là
pour la peine
[Musique]
juste personne te force à rester en fait
ferrer f4 et puis et puis c'est cool en
faites
pas de soucis un
nom mais en vrai
la plainte chaîne qui diffuse le tournoi
tu vas sur une autre chaîne s'est pas
encore en fait
c'est cool
je ne parle pas maintenant mais en fait
tu peux parler d autres fins va sur la
chaîne en espagnol ou en russe il ya
plein de gens qui regardent ils sont
très heureux enfin c'est pas grave enfin
moi ça m'embête pas en fait
ça qu'il faut que tu comprennes
ça ça m'embête par un
don qu'il a joué puis on prend des six
enfants dès six torcéen est fou c'est 8
ok c'est compliqué parce que
la position peut vraiment partir hors de
contrôle
la partie on peut être contre ce qu'on
fait autour des 6 tours c'est un rêve de
fou c'est 8
ouf
pour saint ouen f2 il faut c'est 8 ok
qu'est ce que ça donne en vrai
oui force un peu ce qui hier il a joué
très safe là je suis d'accord
c'est peut-être hier en fait qu'il
fallait forcer mais bon
c'est vrai que ça m'inquiète un peu qui
force cela pas forcément pour cette
partie mais globalement après il dit
peut-être qu'il a aucun risque maxime
ça ça demain mais ça risque d'être la
position dans la partie
après il peut changer les tours jean
retour d un beauf bouffe
recette est il veut sa maxime en vrai ok
peut-être ça c'est une poussette
le fougueux en f3
je crois même pas moi même mais je
pense la finale d'options doit être
drones on
tue peu faire ça et tu rentres pas
et jouer
qu'à
faire bref deux pouces et
800 tours ça noah va peut-être faire ça
bref deux français huit tours d'air
essayé d'enlever les tours pour jouer
sur les pions
ouais
et recettes mais en fait ça fait gagner
un temps au noir bref de roide et 6,3 c5
ça c'est pas cool
bref deux
fosses et six tours d un ça ça peut être
jouable
non c'était fou ces huit pardon vous
invite pour tenir la case de 6
venir là ces six tenir la case
6,03 recettes autour des reins pour ses
sept tours ces 5 jours sur 7
des fouilles 6
donc 1
doit pas vu le gain ouais mais plutôt un
j'aime pas qu'il y avait un gain mais
plots les 20 gars
assis avait un gain mais en tout cas
position et chaude tendu et fierro on
s'est un peu on
s'est juste pièce de plus il n'y a pas
de monde où ira de sa fille au
figaro il n'y a pas un monde où il rate
ça
cheyrou est apparemment nourrira de ça
en pierre en f2 et je pense que c'est 8
et je pense à faire pousser 8
ce que je vois un futur top 3 est
l'étape étape dans ce genre t'as pas un
fier ou
juste et à leur fille rhodia il est pas
intéressé par paraître top 3 au top de
mon avis hein c'est pas trop le délire
ça se sent que son délire c'est juste
d'être champion du monde ça se ressent
ça se ressent en fait
elle fout c'est 8 qui va partir du coup
il va sûrement faire tourner un jeu
penser ce qu'il veut jouer maxime
de match offensif est vraiment de mettre
en fait il est immense dans la vie
réelle
débutants aux échecs et qu'on fait
depuis la main c'est mieux de faire du
normal ou d'oubli c'est mieux de faire
du normal
c'est mieux de faire du normal il a fait
pousser 6 ok vous ces 6 alors qu'est ce
qui gênait vraie fausse et si c'était
pour eux si ce
qui était un intérêt qui semblait
intéressant pour maxime sa coupe le roi
il peut pas attaquer
ils sont grands les lettons et je crois
qu'ils sont grands
l'image d'une donation il sort en
lituanie lettonie et où j'ai
l'impression que c'est des gens qui sont
grands
pays de basket ils sont grands dans les
pays bas que les gens sont grands
theresa à partir au mans au final de
mettre la terre lui a proposé de venir
avec un nombre de points biaisé il a dit
qu'il voulait pas jouer parce qu'il ya
aucune chance de gagner ouais c'est un
bon exemple ça il ya plein d'exemples
comme ça avec avec ali reza où ça
l'intéresse pas de jouer pour la 2e
place
il a fait tout russie souhaite c'est le
coût de la partie
est ce qu il peut y avoir un piège ah ok
bon ça malheureusement c'est même pas un
piège et a poussé deux je me demande est
ce que genre ce genre de truc ça pouvait
être dangereux
il peut vouloir peut-être bkt fougue et
ça ça peut être un joli set up pour les
noirs
ça peut être une idée ça pour les noirs
croix des deux traits fins
et kid est d'essayer de choper les pions
au québec quatre peut être un coup
p45 ou ambitieux pour les noirs en plus
c'est un coup pour jouer le lien entre
guillemets pour les deux époux gras taf
a perdu est ok
ok ok c'était perdant vite yougov qui
revient dans le tournoi je m'y attendais
pas du tout hein parce que bon il était
peut-être facile et du championnat de
russie raté son début de tournoi il
revient peut être dangereux contre vite
yougov tension mais b quattro c'est
typique le genre de coup en fait on
passe dans une partie vraiment à trois
résultats
il faut qu'il l'emmène à andrew scheer
va leur prendre des positions
importantes pile dans les ipod c'est
tout un art ouais mais il faut aussi
qu'ils se retrouvent pas dans une
position où il est mal maxime c'est pas
du tout la même chose que firent
ouchayeh rhin ce que la jambe et 5 ça
peut vraiment devenir double tranchant
c'est vraiment pas clair ce que tout
d'un coup il vous faut b 5e tour b un
tour prend b2 quand même
et il faut faire gaffe
je sais pas g4 cube et cinq tours 4
tours b 1 donc en b 4 prend b2
tout d'un coup ça peut devenir chaud le
roi va monter rapidement là il ya le
plonger de en l'air il ya tous les pions
sur blanc la lépi en sont sûrs noir et
c'est tout tout d'un coup c'est du nord
kivu ligue 1
attention c'est pas du tout la même
c'est pas du tout le même scénario que
firent ou contre
que fuir ou contre nay arrière alors là
pas du tout
ça peut tourner en deux résultats pour
laisser la pole au mans ces trois
résultats avec très grande proportion de
nul et quelques wind des deux côtés mais
ça peut vite tourner en show
pour tout le monde
attention tous réussissent c'est bien ça
joue le ghana font
attention aux scénarios
sur les 90 que les blancs amène l'eau
au centre ld4 trois foulées saint croix
des quatre c'est hyper chaud
peut-être tourin ici j'en sais rien
uturbey a autour un jeu c'est pas ça
peut jouer comme ça
ça peut gagner pour les blancs ça peut
perdre l'aïe a peut-être poussé quatre
faut prendre tout reprend tout reprend
tout reprend tout reprend roi prend tout
reprend tour bouge tout reprend pions
pouces tour lappion pouces tour l'
échec 3f sept à huit dames et ça ça doit
être gagnant pour les blancs alors c'est
un scénario possible en fait des cinq
tout peut arriver bay 4-3 fou
b53 des cats a peut être chaude pour les
deux
toi un roi ses cinq tours prend roi
prend tour à un fou c4
genre de choses je sais pas où ces
quartiers peut-être tour à 4 ici bon
mais pas fous ces quatre un autre coup
j'en refais ou des cinq pour fou
bessette et c'est peut-être plus tôt les
blancs qui joue bien j'en sais rien
ça peut être cool pour les blancs aussi
quand on pousse à l'air plutôt cool pour
les blancs mais je repars mais attention
pour quelques choses peuvent arriver
en tout cas moi j'aimais pas fous ces
six de base se référer fous ces huit
pour tenir la case et ramener le roi
glèlè repoussée si c'est un coup qui m'a
pas plus pour les noirs
soit je dis que c'est fou p 7 pouces et
8 lits dès maintenant mais on a perdu un
temps avec les noirs
jean roy 3 quand même
est sûre pour bientôt rebelles 6 pour b2
vous aussi ce fou j'ai deux tours à 6
c'est hyper chaud
as tu pas organisé de faire k3 ses 5 3
des 6 es fou dessin qui est quelque
chose d'autre
c'est vrai pas trop aimé le fou c'est
ici c'est puis on regarde en fait plus
on se sent que le 3 résultat peut être
de résultats plutôt pour maxime
ça a l'air intéressant
ça peut passer et caruana du coup
rapidement
ça reste
mais qui s'est vu contre un plot
là je pense qu'il s'est hissé planté
vraiment je sais pas fou c'est 8 c'est
un truc qui devait lui déplaire je ne
sais pas lequel mais je pense que
commence à ramener le roi c'était
vraiment important
sacha c'est la tour mais peut-être qu'il
n'aimait pas ça
vous
à voir
the garden yade amende
c'est complètement fou tu tweet alors
y'a rien à voir en fait ça a joué on
s'est même pas vraiment pourquoi
façon c'est pas intéressant pour le
classement
on va s'agresser korobov quatre points
c'est quatre points et demie aussi ou
pas
ce que corroborait corrobore volo kittin
ça remonte aussi attention pas des
joueurs dangereux ça mais korobov s'il
réussit bien maxime normalement
ça peut être cool
mulet qui résiste
max la jeu
la meilleure position qu'il a depuis le
début de la partie
je pense qu'il a jamais été aussi bien
c'est pour moi clairement mais hier sa
meilleure position
ah ben oui bien sûr
c'est une pub ambulants qui part
peut-être au b787
a fait perdre du temps par rapport à ce
qu'il a fait avant il va avoir la même
avec un temps de moins s'il fait ça
et si vous dites que b4 la turbie n'aime
pas avec trois des quatre et c'est vrai
que la variante semblait cool pour les
blancs
il peut être contre sens et un petit peu
en fait shirov iphone et si c'était
vraiment une gaffe
quand ils surfent nous existons russie
c'était vraiment le coup mais
il fait b 4 attention ça craque
oh ça craque
ça craque côté shirov
contre sens tu
l'auras ou trois tempo et ça y est
et ça y est les eps i 3 ans tente
voilà ça va repartir pour maxime ça y
est ça se voit immédiatement que
l'erreur a été fait ou pepsico
et là du coup roi des quatre
west hill drôme et mais c'est hyper
shops 40 qu'on a vu en fait c'était pas
si simple débuts à voir mais roi des
quatre tours un roi c5
tampon à 5 3 point b 4 1 pouces et
quatre non pas fou c'est qu'à part dont
il ya tour à 4 on avait fait foot et 5
et ça ça parait hyper chiant à jouer
pour les noirs parce que roy c'est cinq
rois des six n'est elle pas t'as pas
envie mais un point de jouer ça mais
alors tu as vraiment pas du tout envie
de jouer ça
c'est un cauchemar ça
ça c'est hyper chiant
fouet fin genre je vais pas partir avec
le fouet tapella roi c5 ça c'est relou
de ouf
ça eroglu de ouf
là on voit maximin
ouais je pense je pense qu'il va pas
trouver là
je pense qu'il va pas vous trouvez
je pense qu'il va pas trouver jusqu'au
bout
je pense qu'il va pas tenir jusqu'au
je vous dirais que mon tour un pour les
noirs
jordi suroît 3 x 4
faut prendre quatre mois assurone 3
il a raté sur trois
ou à quatre
points quatre tours 1 est fou des cinq
tours ces cinq
endroits des quatre tours 17 heures à
saint quay il a raté ça
ok mais c'était hyper dur à voir moi
aussi j'avais raté
road 3 x 4 c'est hyper dur fou des cinq
tours c'est 5 avec thor prend 1,5 ok
mais c'était ultra chaud à voir
tour 1 ouais
ouais non ça c'était quasi invisible
maxime a pas vu non plus à mon avenir
parce qu'il avait l'air très content d'y
adjoindre trois tempo
ça peut faire drouot encore alors pour
le temps jusqu'à me reste onze minutes
on est au 36ème coup il reste trois
quatre coups à jouer donc le temps ne
sera pas un problème dans cette partie
pour les quatre coups qui reste
à la variante va s'enchaîner il va
récupérer 50 minutes
je pas si la partie la position est
gagnante pour maxime je crois pas je
crois que je crois que c'est égal encore
mais c'est chiant à jouer pour les noirs
et maxime qui part avec roy c5
safer tour prend à 5 c'est sûr
il va prendre en d4 pour arrêt forcé sur
les phillies et qui aurait pas de
problème de temps je vais trois quatre
coups parce qu'en fait là les coups ils
sont forcés
après mac peut tenter un marabout tourbe
et six pour trois des six tours b 8
maths
et sur foix iv un roi prend b4
tombé 5 tankan b5 faut prendre les 5 et
ça ça doit gagner le roi blanc est trop
bien placé
encore 0 0 ouais et biner la poussette
mais elle va peut-être pas suffire
à l'efo qui craque comme nageur hier
pour des six ressemble à un coup
c'est pas la partie
pour maxime si j'ai l'impression caruana
ça donne quoi on va juste faire un petit
passage rapide pendant que maxime
réfléchi ont ils tendent ce qui peut
mais ça devrait pas suffire les vannes
on s'en fou j'ai envie de dire ouais
chercher où elle et s'y tiennent qu'à
kehl ces gros bordel et s'y tiennent
qu'à il fait vraiment tout pour gagner
il cravache le jeune russe
il cravache
et carrière d'ailleurs juste par
curiosité ce qui se remet
et c'est bien pour lui de faire une
petite doit aujourd'hui
se remet sur pied
et fier où ça chez clariant on s'est
vraiment complètement écrasant il
pourrait vraiment faim il pourrait y
avoir un abandon
trop grands avantages matériels après
fear où la raison de
de gérer et de prendre son temps mais en
soit la partie écrasante a laissé la
bonne nouvelle on va revenir sur maxime
n'a pas joué après tour points 5
dans mon cas
80 retomber si ces rois des six
shirov calcul allez faut ici je pense
qu'il va pas il va faire tomber 6 maxime
le coup le plumard alou
double tranchant qu'ils fassent
attention
ouais
ça peu bizarrement tournée mais il est
quand même bien en contrôle
l'allemand mario mettant v6 en fait
c'est l'hésitation qui l'a clairement le
roi des six tours b vite vont ils encore
faux et vite mais tu sens que les noirs
sont sous pression
quand même l'impression de pas être loin
des avantages blanc
les mieux placés way lourd allemand et
d'un côté mieux placé mais le problème
que tu peux avoir avec les blancs c'est
qu'en fait si ça et ça et ça ça
s'échange et que le roi se redresse
restant b4 en réalité c'est plutôt les
pions blancs qui sont faibles puisque le
roi il sera mieux placée en fuite que le
roi blanc b4 mais je vois pas de
scénario maxime est en danger mais bon
faites le roi si tous les pions
s'échange à l'ale
allèles dame
ça peut être bien mais roye b 4 tours 1
je vois pas dans quel monde tu te
retrouves moins bien avec les blancs
comme
pour b 6 ils ont courbé un roi ses trois
tours j'ai un fou des cinq
fois f1
mais quatre rouges et 2
et 2 tours j'ai deux tours ici tour j'ai
trois rois c4 pour ça que j'ai que ça
peut être à trois résultats parfois
bref cette peut-être b5
george est un
roi des cinq tours b 1
et 6 3 g six
mois ses 6,3 g cinq
b777 trois quatre tours à 3 g 5 aura ses
six f 5 3 des 5 g 4
4 les trois rois et froid trois tours à
maxime qui saigne du nez
du sang dans le masque non vraiment
ce qu'il enlève son masque l'a quand
même
fait toi bizarrement en russie je
saignais du nez alors que je n'ai jamais
donné ici parce que l'air est froid et
sec car je sais pas quelle est la
température qui fait en ce moment à riga
j'ai pas vu en vrai
mais il était en train de se transforme
en super saiyan
et fierro c'est de plus en plus gagnant
avec chaque coup
et là je mais si je m'y attendais à
tomber si je connais mon marlou
bas il est parti en courant nous coincer
qui saigne du nez c'est pas très grave
un de saigner du nez mais bon
bon pas très inquiétant c'est quelque
chose qui arrive de temps en temps
donc surtout va en fait trois des six
tours des noms et pas toi j'ai dit en
fait le faux viande et 5 et on peut vous
encourager à bec cloué
un fou des cinq ça paraît dangereux pour
les noirs à vrai dire
ça paraît dangereux
ce que le roi est quand même bien bloqué
1 est ce tu fais j'ai cinq ans fait tour
bessette on va venir après te couper et
te prendre les pions
ça paraît bien dangereux
c'est dire à mes recettes directes pour
bessette non
des êtres approuvé quatre chiens salon
peut-être ça
faut aussi évaluer cette finale x 4
tours un caprice prise crise prises
prise 3-6
6-3 5-3 bessette ça doit être drôle
parce que la structure blanche est trop
mauvaise de l'autre côté
et enlever son masque elle a eu bien
raison
raison si ce n y
est mais chez rough sous pression encore
trois coups à jouer pour pour chichi
géographie doit être deg de tomber si
cela
dit waremme et toi hein je suis d'accord
avec toi un roi ici tour eu un
ou des 5 c'est relou 1
ça peut être long
elle est
avec les noirs 1 elle est pas agréable
maxime qui a vraiment bien joué la
finale on avait peur qu'ils prennent des
risques et que ça se retourne contre lui
mais pas du tout
c'est un maxime c'est un maxime des
grandes semaines qu'on a
mal
catastrophe pour aronian encore
complètement perdre en ml a des bonnes
éjecté du top niveau
les chiffres officieux là il nous fait
une nayer il nous fait une à hyères
shirov assez terrible
c'est terrible ça va craquer
ça va craquer
différence est il veut aller jouer la
finale
peut se faire d'un verbe il peut se
faire nazer de
recettes jouais
déjà le roi prend b4 en vrai tour 1 et
tours bessette c'est peut-être ça qu'il
faut faire
foot et 7 est pas loin maxime il est pas
loin là
c'est pas loin de craquer la côte et
shirov
c'est pas loin de craquer du tout
il est à deux doigts ja deux doigts de
craquer la chaire of
7 wassa à deux doigts de craquer ça
c'est vraiment pas loin d'être foutu
maxime va prendre b4 va faire tourner
cette il hésite
à roanne signé ça va pour lui ici penco
galant gagnant malheureuse un esprit
ncaa attention et s'y tiennent qu'à
attention s'ils gagnent au noir il va
prendre blanc au prochain
à tence
car dans ce tournoi
il hésite à maxime
sur syfy fois 4-0 à prendre b4
il a joué tour b cette maxime échec
qui forcent fou 17
tonneaux combien onu 39e
food et cette force et ses 39e cou noir
roi prend des 4 maxime qui joue son 40e
et qui se barre
et donc là la question c'est tout re 5
fois qu'à tours cas 3b trois tours à 4
tours d'essais trois décès 3 4 3 6 6 3 à
5 roy bessette
qui me paraît draw personnellement
gk 6
h quatre rois seth ward et 4 rebonds et
6 passes et 4
3 6 et
6,5
[Musique]
ça peut gagner ce truc
ce truc peut gagner ohlala
l'enfoiré de maxime c'est un bel [ __ ]
[ __ ] ce truc peut gagner
c'est incroyable
ce serait qui est pas nul si simple
re5
je sais pas la finale est nulle ou pas
en tout cas il a fait tour 5 il a pris
la décision au 40e
ok c'est chaud
aronian
américaine il a jamais joué dames 4 en
fait c'est juste drôle ils ont signé dro
ici ok on va faire un petit tour firoud
du coup ça fait longtemps que c'est
complètement gagnant au bond
ok bon ça j'ai envie de dire c'est
terminé en fait très longtemps qu'il ya
pas de partie
ça s'est terminé sa abandon
on s'apprécie à vrai dire
il ya des f4 f3 qui commencent à arriver
firouz sava calif ça va aller à la
qualif ouais caruana qui peut revenir
d'ailleurs caronna qui peut jouer fuir
ou demain au blanc attention à lire les
a quand même caruana c'est pas un voire
facile
donc votre rigueur vous savez gagner et
si pink a
terminé à oui est si plein cap hutin qui
va être gagnant
et sur qui on prend ces quatre ans et
six
sur le prend en fou prend
c'est horrible le fou est arrivé tant
visuellement quand tu arrives sur
l'échiquier ça se voit pas mais si fille
anne k va gagner au noir un élan là ça
revient fort en fait derrière faudrait
vraiment que maxime gagnant
s'en fout macho qui n'a pas gagné sahara
n'a eu en guise
ça devrait aller pour sarah n'a
heureusement j'ai envie de dire
korobov qui revient sevian nava
sévillan navarra
c'est en navarre à
quel point de plus pour ses liens et ça
doit être drôle
au caire
cheyrou
georgia ça gagne ferroudja et j'ai envie
de dire il y est quasiment aux candidats
la seule qui peut l'arrêter vrai serait
de prendre noir noir caruana noirs ici
piennes kaiffer 0 sur 2 quoi vous faire
1 2 me sur deux mais du coup ça peut
remonter faudra quand même faire gaffe
parce qu'il peut doubler les noirs
contre d'efforts mais il fait vraiment
l'écart
est donc maxime est ce qu'il est revenu
maxime est revenu et maxime calcul il a
dû vouloir laisser la responsabilité de
la finale du calcul de la finale à
shirov
mais bon moi j'ai envie de dire on
rentre dedans
moi j'ai envie de dire on rentre dedans
elle n'est pas facile celle là
c'est le roi blanc qui al'avantage
d'espacé qui va aller se balader pour
aller choper les pions elle pourrait
gagner
ils pensent que king puzzle game gagne
mais je pense aussi
je pense aussi qu'ils gagnent
je pense que ça gagne en fait
j'ai l'impression qu'elle gagne mais bon
une grosse turbine pour bien analyser
à temps les gens qui proposent ça
ainsi peut-être drôle
à temps mais ça ça gagne
on peut avec les morts
as-tu franges et 2
tu reviens en g3 précéderont
[ __ ]
bon sur ab quatre façons il peut
s'approcher encore plus vite
je peux pas être malin
être malin chute
on avait quatre le coup
mais relever qu'à 3 des 5
h qu'à 3 des 4 3 5 3 6 4 6 3 b3 b6 3b de
rénommée saluant même
15,6 à deux ans près en plus
x 4 bon ça semble assez absolument forcé
mais c'est 14 surchasse base 0 0 ça
al'air gros
mais la seule manière de faire drôle
c'est roy ces cinq
autres à son tour eu quatre tours prend
à quatre reprises prise prise droit
c'est si ça va y être
et après on verra
il ya des chances
giroud déjà ça va gagner un joli but à
l'heure mais là maintenant il est
carrément à +9 sur la turbine est
et vous m'avez yessi piennes kylar
contre gaffe
grèce a bien tourné finalement pour pour
aurel
l'adversaire d'hier il doit sentir
qu'elle est rezaï stresser un fait il
abandonne pas parce qu'il sent le stress
mais à guilers
discipline qu il s'est complètement raté
il allait prendre le four b2 qui était
un gros plots
et du coup ça se passe pas super
à la partie de maxime ali reza je
pensais que la partie se termine après
deux heures de jeu à vrai dire je suis
étonné que ça joue encore
auquel afférents à ces 6 3 à 5 ok
il s'est trompé shirov au où
il s'est trompé propos je crois qu'il
s'est trompé
ce que roy celle ci s'était froissé 5 la
drôme
et oui retourne à l'ehpad papilles oh
c'est terrible il ay là il n'a pas
calculé roi c'est 5
reprend ainsi 3 b 4 roues al-arab et
trois et ça c'était drôle il a fait roi
bessette tempo assez terrible retrait
ted
et oui la gaffe est arrivé
comment tu peux jouer au civil qui s'est
fait damer je sais robbins ait baissé
des joueurs amateurs c'est des retraités
en fait c'est pas le même niveau
c'est comme ça en fait
là encore c'est un peu comme hier quand
le fake five c'est pas des belles
parties en soient
commises et femmes c'est quasi des
partis qui peut avoir en 15 + 10 entre
deux joueurs de haut niveau à vrai dire
c'est pas des gaffes qu'on a l'habitude
de voir quand on suit les candidats aux
jours de tournoi c'est une énorme
rabaissait tempo c'est une gaffe de fou
parce qu'en fait tu dois juste calcul
héros à ses 5,3 6,3 b4 et ses nus
l'instant tu
es là ok c'est pas sûr que ce soit
gagnant mais ça avait des chances tout à
l'heure quand je regardais ça avait
l'air d'être vraiment bien pour les
blancs
mayroy c5 c'est une nulle en force en
fait y'a plus rien à voir enfin c'est
juste du calcul une fois c'est tout
forcé jusqu'au bout
c'est peut-être pas fini encore
il faut gagner des parties comme ça ah
oui et non mathieu juste tu t'attends
pas un truc table deux qualifient
qualificatif aux candidats ronde 8
d'avoir des joueurs aussi faible quand
même
enfin faut comprendre roi joue le 3g 3g
mais c'est très compréhensible du
ferrage et deux parce que tu remonte
vers le pion dans la mathieu c'est
je suis très souvent d'accord avec toi
mais là je suis pas d'accord avec toi
dans un dans un tournant avec un tel
enjeu tu t'attends quand même à la fin
avoir des joueurs qui sont capables de
calculer ça c'est je suis d'accord avec
toi que c'est pas facile facile mais bon
c'est pas insurmontable
c'est comme la partie que de nay arrière
tu t'attends à ce que le mec trouve
quand même 3 et 6 3 5 3 4 3 g iii
pour des parties longues et tout avec
une heure à la pendule ok si tu as dix
minutes ou 15,8 à la pendule je veux
bien mais là avec une heure à la pendule
comme moi c'est 5 tu trouves ça tu
calcules roi ses 5,3 6,3 bk 3b 6-3 b3
c63 larroy là je sais pas
évidemment c'est pas simple simple mais
quand même paris va cette position de
manière forcée est ok tu dois trouver 3
6 3 g 2 mais en soi c'est plus logique
ce que tu reviens vers g3
ces annonces ce qu'ils expriment finir
ça peut finir comme hier oui mais il a
fallu prendre des risques pour maxime
mais c'était pas du tout le même
scénario que la partie d'hier celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout la même
chose en fait c'est le même type de
gaffes parce que shirov il a fait
n'importe quoi mais c'est pas du tout
le même type de finale fait ça à voir
dans la gamme mais ça n'a rien à voir
dans le scénario de jeu
c'est gagner on parle d'ailleurs quand
j'ai l'impression que c'était gagnant
puisque en fait tu vas faire h 4 h 5
est en fête avec les noirs
tu vas te retrouver en fait bloqué
faire à cet endroit c4 et g4 en fait tu
vas être retrouvés en 12 langues
non mais c'est sûr que c'est gagnant
le tempo mais je pense qu'il a compris
avec g4 c'était gagnant en fait il a
compris que c'était face est quand même
étonnant je sais pas quel point il a
tout vu
je sais pas quel point il a tout vu
baky diderot
et je vois pas comment tu d'euros ça en
fait
je n'arrive pas à faire mieux avec les
noirs en fait j'y arrive jamais
turbine donne un petit arrêt à petit sur
bing a aussi plus 0,4 mais en fait je
n'arrive pas à tenir
je vais jouer tous les coups de la
turbine
ça j'aurais jamais défendu comme ça mais
ça va gagner quand même
les gagnants je sais pas comment tu
tiens ça avec les noirs en fait
va faire j'ai 6 mai g5 g5
tard j'en ai perdu une comme ça
la super froid b5
j'ai cinq tiendrais qu'il faut vraiment
le faire maintenant alors
j'ai cinq seul coup
c'est un quad à voir je leur avais 7
tempo un prix laférois cette eau il a
rien compris le papy il a rien compris
la shirov
il a rien compris à la finale il n'a
même pas compris qu'il était perdant en
fait
il a rien compris le frérot c'est
terrible
on n'arrive pas quel point c'est gagnant
ou pas
j'arrive jamais à défendre donc on va
voir
il faut en fait s'il va les jouer tempo
dans la gueule je vous annonce h41 là je
n'en savent pas trop de maxime
petit riff rh 4 h 5 il va le vice et il
aura les coudes attentes
shirov c'est sûr qu'il n'a rien vu parce
que sinon ils auraient calculé roi ses
cinq passes et k3 b3 il joue tout à
tempo comme si c'était nul facile
et alireza il a toujours pas signé a
wind
systems nervis conçu heures pour ali
reza a évoqué ses 17 d'éviter un échec
et d'emprunts f4
d'amd c'est ça danbé 4d vitam échec
terminée alireza ça va sinon on va juste
aller voir
ça y est la main été signé
c'est gagner on a raté la signature
victoire d'ali reza à lire les sacs pas
encore au candidat mais il s'en approche
bravo à lui c'est bien sachez qu'à
remplir mais les pièces quand même
reconversion en arbitre peut-être pour
la suite du tournoi
mais belle victoire d'ali reza et ça
fait plaisir
allez rezaï est quasiment
sas et j'ai une bonne chose de faite h4
avait cet
hommage signe comme quoi
si rouge atteint 14,4 monde
et peut-être
peut-être bientôt top 3 attendez je vais
aller jeter un oeil à sa
presse à bientôt
c'est du caca aujourd'hui peut-être même
bientôt top 3 pour ali reza mieux classé
que nepomniachi
donc ça c'est fait et caruana en parlant
du loup et caruana par contre il est
bien ça ça peut être loupé ça par contre
ça peut être long
il était en train de la gagner ou pas
dur à dire et s'ils tiennent qu'à
vienne cas il s'est mis dans la merde
tout seul bonne nouvelle j'ai envie de
dire à doolow a perdu contre part in oh
j'ai toujours dit que ce joueur n'avait
pas le calibre d'un joueur du haut
niveau
ça fait plaisir on peut être demain
petit au pari nouvelle les couleurs sont
correspondantes
aux boys
au nom draw
aux non non on n'y croyait en fait
non on ya cru en vrai
h5 brender à merde
on n'a pas compris comment c'était gagné
ou pas mais on a vu que c'était
dangereux
je n'arrivais jamais à faire nul contre
l'ordi en fait parce que je l'aimé qu'on
leur dit je perdais
était à troyes b 5 ici vrai qu'on n'ait
pas vu de base
on ya cru mais ça doit être drôle
bon faudra que j'analyse avec une horde
et un ordinateur puissant
sais pas s'il a vraiment raté une chance
à la clim
ouais chimed
climat est bien joli shirov viendrait
shirov
fera sa santé quand même sa santé bons
rails devait pas pouvoir la gagner
ça partait de l'autre côté
ouais ça devait être drôle quand je
jouais avec les noirs j'arrive à faire
drôle en fait
voilà c'est terrible il a rien louper
c'est terrible on y avait cru
un cru
assez terrible
ça devait être drôle moi j'avais pas vu
en fait cette idée là de base
ça devait être d'euros
à terrible
ce qu'on aurait pu avoir max et avait
d'un machin c'est terrible
ad ouais c'est terrible une place qui se
libère les pattes de rien
m
j'espérais j'espérais qu'on ne l'a pas
fait froid c'est sain qu'il annule en
force qui est un problème mais ce
n'était pas le cas
en main terrible
terrible résumé un peu des régionales
dont firent août jacky gagné qui a un
point d'avancé complet sur sur le reste
mais ça revient derrière
ça revient derrière de ouf
vite yougov au pari n'est korobov qui
rattrape mvl way
alex enhco qui bat tabataba
vian qui va revenir aussi qui va battre
navarra
on ça revient ça revient fort hein
ça rien de partout sur maxime
bon après y'a le départage qui va bien
pour le moment c'est cool
j'ai trois rois c'est trois quatre
importants rabais 7 3 puis tu prends
l'opposition tuant des cas décidé en
haut à g ici
ça donne finale de dame proche de gains
du moins dangereuse pour les noirs est
donc il a bien raté quelque chose maxime
dans la finale de pions
c'est dommage
c'est dommage c'est dommage s'il a raté
poussette c'est dommage
c'est dommage c rater s'il a raté énorme
poussette c'est dommage parce qu'il
aurait pu le faire craquer
ouais s'ils pouvaient pousser c'est
dommage
c'est nul c'est dommage de ne pas
attenter poussette
maxime garde le destin son destin entre
les mains il faudra doubler les blancs
j'ai envie de dire un moment donné à
voir une fois de plus les blancs ça peut
être bien mais là avec les noms il
pourra jouer en contre ont tout reste à
faire tout reste à faire
tout cas on rappelle que la bonne
nouvelle de la journée firoud de jacky
s'est lui imposé qui prend vraiment le
large il va taper il va taper du lourd
demain a dit rezaï jouera au noir ça
c'est sûr à 100% et maxime on va espérer
qu'ils doublent et blanc
on va voir on va espérer on va espérer
que maxime
ya eu aussi
sur nos mains sur les deux france ô
combien perso je prends quand même oui
oui oui bon on prend quand même mais
on aimerait bien avoir les deux
aujourd'hui ces trous et wes ça
m'inquiète un peu aussi grande et husky
ce trou
équivalent et ses
vallées ses remontées
fabi peut-être
ouais ça peut habillée avec les blancs
contre ali reza attention attention à
fabiano avec les pièces blanches il
cravache en tout cas un joueur américain
parce que c'est vrai qu'après fabiano
gagné avec les bleus contre ali reza ça
peut remettre carrément tout le monde en
tout le peloton en
enjeu
ça va être ça va être ton dax ça va être
tendu que cette fin de tournoi
après il ya au pari qui peut avoir les
coureurs correspondante avec maxime
ça peut être un adversaire intéressant
mais au pari qui va sûrement serrer le
jeu on verra
bon jeu et difficile les gars tout à
l'heure on aura fable qui viendra faire
des petites parties pédagogique
attendez je vais lui écrire
je crois qu on fera ça ce sont surtout
les faire ça vers huit neuf heures vers
9 heures chemin on fait la vidéo vers 8
heures elle est partie avec fable ce
soir donc vous retrouverez fab ce soir
moi je vous dis à tous chacha remercie
encore d'avoir suivi cette journée je
vous envoie le raid sur chaise comme du
coup
si vous voulez suivre la suite avec les
joueurs américains merci à vous encore
d'avoir suivi à deux matchs a enfin tout
à l'heure et puis avait pu à demain pour
la suite du tournoi merci à tous cha cha